AND JUST GOOD MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME OF THE
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN. RESEARCH THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS.
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE PARTICIPATION IN THIS
PUBLIC FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
SESSION TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR IS THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TWO
DAYS PARTICIPANTS- NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX.
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY THREE AT
877-226-8160 THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO FOUR SIX TWO. AT. SEVEN SIX
TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM REMOTE
MEETING SERVICES OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY IN
THE OLD STREET BUILDING. AND I
ASKED ALL MY MEMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE- TO MAKE THEIR WAY TO
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE CAN
STOP THE CORPSMAN BEGAN OUR
HEARINGS. WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS-
OUT TODAY TO WHICH- ON CONSENT
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ACHEN TO NOT SPEAK
THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
WAY SO. AND SP TEN SEVENTY TWO
BY SENATOR DOLLY HAS BEEN POURED
FROM TODAY'S AGENDA. SO I WE
WILL HEAR TESTIMONY- RIGHT NOW
AGAIN LACKING A QUORUM BUT WE
WILL HEAR. WE HAVE SENATOR
BACKER YOU PREPARED. YES YOU
YOUR FIRST ITEM IS S. B. ONE
THOUSAND. MR SHARE. RESCUE ONE
THOUSAND WILL PROTECT THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS THAT'S
REPORT AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE COMMUNICATIONS VIA POLICE
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS SERVER ON
THEIR COMMUNITIES THE POLICE
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS ACCESS FOR
SEVENTY PLUS YEARS NEWS OUTLETS
JOURNALIST A PUBLIC HAD ACCESS
TO THIS INFORMATION. IN ITS
GRIPPING PORT FOR TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND REPORTING
PUBLIC SAFETY ACTIVITY TO THE
PUBLIC. UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW
THERE IS AN ALARMING TREND
OCCURRING IN CALIFORNIA. WHICH
HAS FOR POLICE DEPARTMENTS
MOVING TO FULLY G. CRAFT THAT'S
OUR FULLY ENCRYPTED WERE BLOCKED
THE READING COMMUNICATIONS. IN
THE NAME OF PROTECTING-
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE CAN IN FACT
PROTECT PRIVATE INFORMATION
WITHOUT PUTTING THE PUBLIC IN
THE DARK IF YOU CHRISTIAN. SO
THIS BILL SB ONE THOUSAND
SIMULTANEOUS GRANTS OPTIONS AND
FLEXIBILITY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE'RE CONSIDERING UPGRADING THE
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS. AND
PROJECT AND PROTECTING THIS
COUNTRY FROM NATION WE SPOKE
WITH POLICE CHIEFS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERS LOCALLY AND
EVERYONE MUST BE TRANSPARENT IN
THE RADIOCOMMUNICATIONS BUT
ALSO BE COMPLIANT. WITH A
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. SO WHICH
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT'S A FALSE
CHOICE TO SAY DEPARTMENTS MUST
SPEND MILLIONS TO ENCRYPT BLOCK
ALL ACCESS THANK YOU SIR- YOU
KNOW WORK LEAST PUBLIC
INFORMATION THERE IS A THIRD
OPTION WHICH WILL TALK ABOUT A
BIT FULL OF CORRUPTION IS ONLY
STREAM IT'S NOT NECESSARY IF AT
THIS POINT WE SEE SUPPORT FOR
PRIVACY ORGANIZATIONS STATING
THIS AS WELL. AND WE BELIEVE WE
FOUND THE RIGHT BALANCE HERE FOR
EXAMPLE ARE THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL HAS FIGURED THIS
OUT UPON RECEIVING THE DOJ'S
GUIDANCE IN TWENTY TWENTY TO SEE
SPEAK QUICKLY AND CHEAPLY
ADOPTED A POLICY TO TRAIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DISPATCHERS TO
PROTECT. SO I DEFINITELY
PERMISSION AND THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO KNOW. THE CSP POLICY
MEETS OUR REQUIREMENTS OF
DEPARTMENTS CAN DO THE SAME. I
APPLAUD THE USE OF WEB PORTAL
AND SOCIAL MEDIA TECH TOOLS BY
POLICE. BUT THOSE ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT TO GRANT TRUE OUT
LIVE AT TRANSPARENCY. A FORMER
ACCESS PLEASE ACTIVITIES NOT
OPERATIONAL CHANGE THAT SHOULD
BE TAKEN WITHOUT INPUT FROM THE
PUBLIC ELECTED OFFICIALS AS IT
FORCES BEEN HAPPENING NOW. IN
DOZENS OF CITIES. ACROSS OUR
STATE. NOW CERTAINLY NOT TE
TIME TO STRICT ACCESS TO POLICE
RADIO IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
WHILE MANY POLICE DEPARTMENTS
HAVE A GOOD FAITH MADE THIS
TRANSITION TO FOR CORRUPTION
IT'S NOT UP TO US TO CORRECT
THAT MISTAKE ENSURE CONSISTENCY-
AS WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
BILL SO. THEY'RE WORKING WITH
CLOSE WITH YOU A DOJ AND A HOST
OF STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS
JOURNALISTS BROADCASTERS
ADVOCATES WE CONTINUE HAVE
CANDIDA PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS. WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS SO WHEN IT
THANK- OUR SPONSORS ACCOMPANY
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION. AS WELL AS PALTROW
DAILY POST AT OUR DAY PRICE FOR
DRAMATIC ATTENTION TO
DISBURSEMENT. OUT RIGHT CONCERN
I THINK YOU HAVE TO- WITNESSES
READY. WE WILL GIVE EACH SIDE
FOUR MINUTES BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION SERBIA TWO WITNESSES
WILL GIVE THEM TWO MINUTES EACH-
YOUR FIRST WITNESS MAY BEGIN
THEIR TESTIMONY. THEIR PHONE OR
IN PERSON WAS SORT OF THE PHONE
WITH JENNIFER AND THEN BRITNEY'S
HERE IN PERSON. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
BRIEFLY SHARE WITH YOU WHY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE
THOUSAND. I'M JENNIFER SEELIG
DIRECTOR OF NEWS AND PROGRAMMING
FOR KCBS ALL NEWS RADIO WHICH
BROADCASTS LIVE FROM THE BAY
AREA TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. WE ARE
THE PRIMARY OR L. P. ONE
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM STATION.
I OPENED ALSO REPRESENT
JOURNALISTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF RTDNA THE
RADIO TELEVISION DIGITAL NEWS
ASSOCIATION. JOURNALISTS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO INFORM THE
PUBLIC DURING NATURAL DISASTERS.
MASS SHOOTINGS. OTHER MAJOR NEWS
EVENTS. SCANNER COMMUNICATION IS
CRUCIAL TO OUR NEWS GATHERING
EFFORT. WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE DOING IN
REAL TIME. THE DECISION BY A
NUMBER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO FULLY ENCRYPT THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS. GREATLY LIMITS
THE ABILITY OF JOURNALISTS TO
SERVE THE PUBLIC. WE ALSO RELY
ON SCANNER COMMUNICATION TO STAY
SAFE IN THE FIELD. NEWS CREWS
ARE INCREASINGLY TARGETED WENT
ON ASSIGNMENT. SCANNER TRAFFIC
ALSO CLARIFY FOR JOURNALISTS
WE'RE NOT TO GO. SO THAT WE
DON'T ACCIDENTALLY INTERRUPT OR
INTERFERE WITH AN EMERGENCY
OPERATION. DURING UNDERSTAND AND
RESPECT THE SENSITIVE NATURE OF
SCANNER COMMUNICATION. AS AN
INDUSTRY STANDARD WE DO NOT
REPORT UNCONFIRMED OR PRIVATE
INFORMATION FROM RADIO
TRANSMISSION. WE USE THIS
INFORMATION TO MAKE COVERAGE
DECISIONS. WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
BETTER OPTIONS THAN FULL
ENCRYPTION TO BALANCE THE
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO PRIVACY
AND THE PUBLIC'S NEED NOW. SB
ONE THOUSAND IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE SAFETY SECURITY
AND WELL BEING OF THE PUBLIC AND
WORKING JOURNALISTS. I AM PROUD
TO PROVIDE. MY SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU BEFORE WE CONTINUE
TESTING COME. CAN WE CALL
ROWLANDS SCORE. BRADFORD EFFORT
HERE JOE BOTH TROUBLED HERE COM
LAGER SCANNER. SKINNER HERE
WINNER WE HAVE A QUORUM
REMEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
CAN CONTINUE NOW THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRITTANY
BAR SAUDI I'M THE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB ONE
THOUSAND WE REPRESENT OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PUBLICATIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
OUR JOURNALISTS RELY ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO BE ABLE TO- UP
ON THESE RADIO ENCRYPTION SO BE
ABLE TO REPORT ON THE ACTIVE
ONGOING DEVELOPING SITUATIONS.
THAT ARE CRUCIAL TO MAKING SURE
THE PUBLIC HAS ACCURATE
INFORMATION AND CAN REMAIN SAFE
WHEN THESE TYPES OF SITUATIONS
ARE ONGOING. I WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES
THE DOJ MEMO IN OUR PERSPECTIVE
BECAUSE IT ALL UP IT CLARIFIES
THAT THE OPTIONS SHORT OF FULL
ENCRYPTION HELP STRIKE THAT
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND
ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEED AND OUT SO. WE'VE
RESPECTFULLY OR DRIVE OUT. THANK
YOU NOW WE'LL GO TO OUR
MODERATOR ARE THEIR COLLARS
ONLINE WISHING TO SUPPORT US
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THOUSAND. MODERATOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE DIALING IN. IN
LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD LUCK WITH CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
QUICKNESS. THANK YOUR MIND
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
JACKIE WITH OPEN PRIVACY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THOUSAND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER PERSON IN
Q. LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. STRAWBERRY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION A COALITION
COMPRISED OF THE NATIONAL PRESS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION THE
RADIO TELEVISION NEWS DIGITAL
ASSOCIATIONS YORK COUNTY PRESS
CLUB THE SAN DIEGO CHAPTER OF
THE SOCIETY OF PROFESSIONAL
JOURNALISTS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK JOURNALISTS
THE SOCIETY OF PROFESSIONAL
JOURNALISTS LOS ANGELES THE
ONLINE NEWS ASSOCIATION AND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU I FEEL DALLAS IS
THERE ANY ONE HERE PRESIDENT
THAT IS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE THOUSAND OTHER THAN A
WITNESS ARTISTS BOOK ARTANE NINE
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION-
THEY WILL BE ENTITLED TO FOUR
MINUTES FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION- WHICH SELLS AUTO
PLEASE WELCOME. MORE MATURE
MEMBERS COURCELLES ALONE BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTIVELY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE AS YOU
KNOW AND AS WAS MENTIONED IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ISSUED GUIDANCE- THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES USE THAT
USE CLASS RE REAFFIRMING STATE
AND FEDERAL POLICY ABOUT
PROTECTING BOTH CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INFORMATION AND PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION IN
SHORT THE BULLETIN SAYS THAT YOU
CAN EITHER ENCRYPT YOUR RADIO
TRAFFIC OR DEVELOP POLICIES TO
RESTRICT DISSEMINATION OF
SPECIFIC TYPES OF INFORMATION.
TO COMPLY WITH THIS REQUIREMENT.
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE UNDERSTAND
FEDERAL LAW SOME AGENCIES HAVE
ENCRYPTED THEIR RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS. THIS BILL
DEFAULTS TO UNENCRYPTED RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS WHICH MEANS THERE
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON
AGENCIES THAT WANT TO TREMENDOUS
EXPENSE TO DEVELOP THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY- OR HAVE PREVIOUSLY
ENCRYPTED THEIR COMMUNICATIONS
TO SWITCH BACK TO UNENCRYPTED
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS. WILL
REQUIRE COSTLY AND TIME TIME
CONSUMING TRAINING IN ORDER TO
PROTECT BOTH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INFORMATION AND THE
PERSONAL IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION. ALSO THE BILLS
CONTEMPLATION OF USING ALTERNATE
NON BROADCASTING ALTERNATIVES TO
RADIO TECHNOLOGY MAY NOT BE EASY
EASY OR ACHIEVABLE IN ALL
LOCATIONS- BECAUSE OF
UNAVAILABLE CELL SERVICE OR
COMPUTERS THAT CAN'T CONNECT-
SWITCHING TO ENCRYPTED OR
ALTERNATE. MEDIA IN TACTICAL
UNDER COVER SITUATIONS WILL
LIKELY COMPLICATE ALREADY
COMPLEX AND OREOS. THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROLS IN A
DIFFERENT SITUATION THEY USE
DIFFERENT RADIOS BECAUSE THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE OVER DIFFERENT
DISTANCES THAN MORE SMALLER
AGENCIES- THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
THEY HAVE TO STAY ON WHAT'S
CALLED THE LOW BAND AS OPPOSED
TO THE HIGH BAND WHICH ALLOWS
FOR ENCRYPTION. SO THE C. H. P.
ISN'T KIND OF A DIFFERENT BOAT
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT IT LOOKS
pENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SO NOT NOT
A KNOCK ON THE HIGHWAY PATROL
THEY JUST HAVE A DIFFERENT
SITUATION SO. IT'S NOT REALLY A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S A BAR
HERE SO- WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE AND TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED AND OPPOSITION. R. NOW
WE'LL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MODERATOR TO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES DESIRING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE THOUSAND.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU'RE IN A
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AT THIS TIME NO ONE HAD
QUEUED UP. OKAY WE'LL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS P. ONE THOUSAND CENTERS CAN
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOUR
BRADFORD- AND- SENDER BACKER FOR
BRING THIS BILL- I APPRECIATE
THE- THE WITNESS IN OPPOSITION-
INDICATING THEIR OPPOSITION BUT
I DID NOT GET FROM YOUR
DESCRIPTION ANYTHING THAT WAS
REALLY FUNDAMENTAL AS TO WHY
THESE COMMUNICATIONS WOULD NEED
THIS TYPE OF ENCRYPTION AND THUS
BE- NOT ACCESSIBLE BY OUR MEDIA
NETWORKS. AND YOU KNOW MAYBE
THERE IS. MAYBE I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND BUT DID NOT SEEM TO
BE IT'S THE KIND OF SITUATION
WHERE IT SEEMS TO ME THE ONLY
TIME THAT WE SHOULD. DO SUCH AN
ENCRYPTION THAT WOULD BASICALLY
PREVENT. OUR- YOU KNOW-
JOURNALISTEN SUCH FROM BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS IS IN REAL IN A
REAL- PUBLIC SAFETY EMERGENCY
AND WHEN I SEE REAL THAT'S KIND
INADEQUATE BUT RATHER IT'S A
LIFE OR DEATH TYPES OF
SITUATIONS AND EVEN EITHER THE
ANALYSIS OR THE DESCRIPTION
REALLY COMMUNICATED THAT WEIRD
THAT WOULD MIGHT BE THE CASE.
AND- RIGHT- CENTER RECORD- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY YOU THINK THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT I THINK THAT
THERE SHOULD BE THIS AND YOU'RE
PRESENTED IT BUT IS THERE ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE WHERE THEY ARE WERE
THERE WOULD BE AN ASSESSEE TO
HAVE SUCH AN ENCRYPTION. I'M NO
WE DON'T WE DON'T FORESEE A
SITUATION WHERE WE NEED FULL
ENCRYPTION EFFECTIVELY TALK TO
DOJ- THEY'RE THEY'RE VERY CLEAR
ON THAT THAT FOCUS IS NOT
REQUIRED NOW- WE'RE CERTAINLY
URGING THEM AND THEY THEY- SAY
THEY'VE BEEN CLEAR THAT. IT WAS
REQUIRED ALL ALONG- AND THAT
THAT THAT THIS IS AN ALTERNATIVE
THAT- EVERYONE SHOULD VERY MUCH
AVAIL THEMSELVES TO WORK. WHEN I
CLEAR GUIDANCE WAS ALWAYS- CLEAR
IN THE PAST FROM DOJ WERE
STRONGLY URGING THEM TO.
CONTINUE TO CLARIFY GOING
FORWARD- BUT THEY HAVEN'T SAID
OR NO ONE HAS SAID THAT THERE'S
ANY. SITUATION WHERE YOU NEED TO
HAVE FOR CORRUPTION. I'M I
SUPPORT THE BILL AND- WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE I WOULD MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR TROUBLED- GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU TO MISTER
CHAIR AND- THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- BEING THAT I AM NOT AN
pEXPERT IN OUR PUBLIC SAFETY AND
LEARNING QUITE A BIT. I DO HAVE
SOME WRITTEN STATEMENTS HERE
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO- PUT IN THE
RECORD. AND FIRST OF ALL MOST
STRONG BELIEVER THE FIRST
AMENDMENT VERY VERY MUCH SO AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT OUR
JOURNALISTS PLAIN IMPORTANT
PUBLIC SAFETY ROLE IN OUR
SOCIETY AND I BELIEVE OUR
CITIZENS HAVE A RIGHT TO
REASONABLE ACCESS FOR PUBLICLY
FUNDED INSTITUTIONS. HOWEVER I
DO BELIEVE THAT OUR SMALLER
POLICE DEPARTMENTS WHO HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF MONEY. UPGRADING
THEIR SYSTEMS FOLLOWING THE
TWENTY TWENTY MEMO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN. OVER THE
ABILITY TO INSTITUTE ANOTHER
OVERHAUL. TO THEIR SYSTEMS.
CHANGE IT BACK TO THE F.
TWINNING CRYPTID SYSTEM AS WELL
AS THE CLUB'S PRIVATE CHANNEL
WOULD BE EXTREMELY COSTLY. FOR-
AND DIFFICULT FOR OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS TO IMPLEMENT I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CHP HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DEVELOP A MORE NEW
WINCED OUR SYSTEM THAT THREAD
THE NEEDLE BETWEEN PRIVACY
CONCERNS AND LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
ACCESS. THE CHP IS A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION WITH CONSIDERABLE
MORE FUNDING THAN MANY OF OUR
LOCAL DEPARTMENTS WHO STRUGGLE
TO MAKE ENDS MEET. AND HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED A FUNDED PILOT
PROGRAM FOR POLICE DEPARTMENTS
TO LOOK AT THE BEST WAY TO
IMPLEMENT A MORE BALANCED
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE CHP HAS. BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH SO THAT THERE IS A
MODEL FOR SMALLER DEPARTMENTS TO
FOLLOW. WELL I THINK ONE OF THE
- THROUGH FRIDAY DRESS HERE IS
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY MUCH CHEAPER
TO NOT FULLY CRAP SO FOR EXAMPLE
SAN BRUNO IN MY- IN MY DISTRICT
IS REACHING OUT FOR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO MOVE IN LARGE PART
JUST TO MOVE TO A- FULL QUESTION
BECAUSE THAT WAS THEIR
INTERPRETATION OF THE DOJ MEMO.
AND WHICH IS WHAT WE THINK DJ
CLARIFYING THAT EARLIER WOULD BE
WOULD BE BETTER- BUT THAT'S-
SWEAT WHILE WE THINK THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE WE TELL
THEM- IT WAS REALLY OUR JOB TO
TELL THEM THAT- ACTUALLY YOU
PROBABLY DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT
RIGHT AND THAT IF I DON'T SPEND
ANYTHING. AND IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
CHEAP WAYS TO MOVE FORWARD AND
JUST MAKE SURE LIKE CHP HAS
DONE- TO MAKE SURE THAT
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION IS NOT GOING OUT
THERE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF. OF
OF WAYS TO DO THAT SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUGGESTION BUT I
THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR LOOKING
CHP WORK YOU KNOW MANY OTHER
AGENCIES WERE DOING AT THAT
THERE ARE WAYS TO JUST MAKE SURE
THE PERSONAL INFORMATION DOESN'T
GO OUT. ON UNDER THE CURRENT
CURRENT CHANNEL SO I DON'T I
PIECES YES I DON'T THINK WE NEED
A PILOT TO SHOW THAT- AND I
THINK THIS BILL IS NEEDED
BECAUSE ONE MAKE SURE MORE
POLICE DEPARTMENT DOES BUT ALL
THE MONEY TO MOVE TO FOREIGN
CORRUPTION WHICH- AGAIN WE THINK
IT'S NOT NECESSARY AND- HARMFUL
TO THE PUBLIC. THEN I HAVE. ONE
MORE QUESTION SIR MISTER CHAIR.
I'M ALSO. MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SCANNERS THAT
CAN MONITOR- READER TRAFFIC PLUS
WHAT NARCOTICS AND GANG UNITS
USED ENCRYPTION DURING THEIR
OPERATIONS- AND THEN THEY CAN
ALSO SUBPOENA RADIO TRAFFIC AS
WELL SO THE PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION BASED ON MANY
SCANNERS. I WAS ADVISED TO GO
INTO THE APP STORE AND SEE HOW
MANY AT LEAST SCANNERS WERE
AVAILABLE- FOR PEOPLE TO USE AN
EVERYDAY BASIS AND THE CONCERN
THAT HAS ARISEN IS THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO MAKE IT A LITTLE EASIER
TO HAVE. THE VARIOUS ACTORS NO
WITH THE MOVE BY MOVE OR AFP OUT
YOUR PERSONAL INFORMATION OR
STRATEGY INFORMATION BY OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS GIVE ANY
FEEDBACK ON THE- BUT MIGHT ASK
MORE MY WITNESSES WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT I THINK IT'S EASIER FOR
YOUR FIRST POINT- I THINK WITH
FOR CORRUPTION THE PUBLIC'S NOT
GETTING INFORMATION AND I THINK
THE WITNESSES. THAT COULD SPEAK
TO THAT- IN TERMS OF- YOU KNOW.
BAD ACTORS I THINK WHAT I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THEY CAN
BE THE BAD ACTORS CAN GET
INFORMATION WHETHER CERTAIN
GROUPS THAT ARE NOT- SO I CAN'T
QUITE COMMENT ON THAT I DON'T
THINK. I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
BILL WILL- AGAIN BECAUSE WE MAKE
SURE PERCENT AFFIRMATION IS NOT.
IS NOT GETTING OUT- WE'LL BE ANY
WILL CREATE ANY ADDITIONAL
DANGERS TO. TO THE TO THE PUBLIC
BUT BUT JUST WHEN THE WITNESSES
ONE ADDRESS EITHER EITHER THOSE
POINTS. JENNIFER FEEL LIKE I
WOULD SIMPLY SAY I THINK YOU
KNOW YOU'VE HAD IT SPOT ON
YOU'RE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
AND YOUR ASSESSMENT I'M HAPPY TO
EXPLORE THIS TOPIC FURTHER IF
YOU HAVE MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT. BRITAIN'S GOOD MORNING
AND- SO AS TO THE LATTER PART OF
THE QUESTION THERE WAS ASKED
ABOUT- NEFARIOUS ACTORS BEING
ABLE TO MONITOR SO THE BILL
LANGUAGE DOES CONTAIN AN
EXEMPTION FOR UNDERCOVER
OPERATIONS AND OTHER ISSUES-
ISSUES THAT WOULD BE COVERED I
BELIEVE UNDER YOUR QUESTIONS SO
THAT'S A DRESSED IN THE BILL
LANGUAGE HOW DOES THAT ACTUALLY
LOOK I APOLOGIZE. THAT THIS
REPORT BUT YES OUR FOOTFALL.
YOUR SO HOW DOES THAT LOOK IN
PRACTICE HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY
PROTECTIVE GEAR HAVE RIDDLED THE
AXIS AND HOW DOES THAT. RETIRED
ACTUAL PRACTICE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNDER COVER OR- ATTACKED.
THE SYSTEM FROM THE VARIOUS
ACTORS. SO TO BE FAIR I'M NOT AN
EXPERT ON THE POLICE END OF
THINGS- WE ARE NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS MONITOR THE
ENCRYPTION FOR THE PENAL CODE
DOES ALSO MAKE IT A CRIME TO
SHARE ANY INFORMATION THAT'S
ONGOING THAT WOULD AID IN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT'S AN
EXISTING LAW WASN'T NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
PERSPECTIVE BUT IN PRACTICE WHEN
YOU WANT TO HAVE READILY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION IT'S JUST
ME I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SEE HOW.
THE SYSTEM IN PLACE TO BE-
PROTECTED FROM HAVING FULL
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION AS ITS
ON GOING. LIVE FROM THE
NEFARIOUS ACTORS KNOWING THIS
THE STEP BY STEP STRATEGIES FIRE
PUBLIC SAFETY. I JUST I I'M ALL
ABOUT THE FIRST AMENDMENT BUT
I'M ALSO WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC
SAFETY- BOTH LOCAL AND FEDERAL
I'M VERY VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT
PROTECTING BOTH THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE TRYING TO. PROTECT OUR
SAFETY ON ON BOTH LEVELS AS WELL
AS- THE STRATEGIES IN WHICH
THEY'RE WORKING IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO- PROCEED WITH THEIR-
TRANSACTION PER SE- THAT'S THAT
WAS THERE. THE INTENT OF MY
QUESTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS- WINNER YEAH RESEARCH
CONTRACT FACT. ALL RIGHT BOSTON
REBEKAH THANK YOU FOR I THINK A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE- YES
PUBLIC SAFETY IS A WHILE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SECURITY IS OF THE
UTMOST CONCERN ALL OF US HERE
BUT I THINK ALSO ACCESS TO.
PUBLIC INFORMATION TRANSPARENCY
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT-
pMORE TRANSPARENT USE BETTER
ALWAYS REGARD TO WHAT PART OF
GOVERNMENT SURE AND SO I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THOSE IN THE FUTURE NO
OTHER QUESTIONS REMEMBERS ALL OF
YOUR CLOTHES. YEAH THANKS TO SET
IT BEGAN WE'RE JUST RESTORING
WHAT WAS IN PLACE FOR SEVENTY
YEARS SO- WE'RE NOT QUITTING ANY
REALLY NEW ACCESS SO THAT THE
LAWS WERE IN PLACE WE'RE NOT
REPLACING CORRUPTION I THINK TO
JUST TO EUROPE WHEN SENATOR
BROKE UP WERE NOT PUT TOO
BECAUSE OF PROTECTION DIVERSE
ACTORS WHICH IS WITH THIS
CONCERN I'M PROUD OF PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DRESS YOUR MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT PERSONAL INFORMATION
WHILE ALSO RESTORING A PUBLIC
ACCESS WHAT THEY'VE HAD FOR
SEVEN YEARS. SO WITHOUT A
STRICTLY ASTRONAUT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE PASS TO PRO. REVENUE MOTION
CENTER SCANNER. COUNSEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON AS P. ONE
THOUSAND. SP ONE THOUSAND
BRADFORD PARK BRADFORD I'D
SHOWBOAT NO JOB NO COM LONGER HI
COME UNDER I. SCANNER. SCANNER I
WINNER WINNER I'D VOTE FOR THE
ONE. MAJOR US FOR VOTES ONE OF
FOUR I AND NO ONE NIGHT IN A
MEASURE PASSES- BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO YOUR SECOND BILL- COUNCIL
CAN WE- PLEASE CALL THE.
CONCERNED COUNTY WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT. CAN CALENDAR.
BRADFORD DIETRO BOGUE. TURBO GUY
COME LONGER COMMA- I SKINNER.
SKINNER I WINNER. WINNER OF FIVE
FIVE ZERO SIX DOLLARS OUT FIVE
ZERO NEXT WE HAVE S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY SINGER BACKER. WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN- GOOD
MORNING THIS IS EIGHT A BILL S.
TWO ONE ONE SEVEN WILL PERMIT
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER OR O. S. P. D. TUITION
GRANT MAKING TO DELIVER CRITICAL
RESOURCES AND ELEVATE INNOVATIVE
PRACTICES AND OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDER PROGRAMS AND OFFICES
ACROSS. THE STATE PRIOR TO THIS
BILL COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICERS IN PROGRAMS APPLY ONLY
TO THE B. S. C. C. FOR FUNDING A
BORDER STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. APPLE TWENTY TWO A
BUNCH ACT ESTABLISHED INDIGENT.
DEFENSE GRANT PROGRAM A PROBABLY
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
WHICH FLOW TO BE A CC FOR
ALLOCATION. I WOULD MAKE MORE
SENSE FOR- S. P. D. AS THE
INDIANS INDIGENT DEFENSE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS TO FACILITATE
THIS WORK IN THE
SERVICES LIKE CONNECTING CLIENTS
TO HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH ID
CARDS DRIVER'S LICENSE BIRTH
CERTIFICATES PUBLIC TRANSIT
PASSES CALFRESH MEDI CAL. ARE
SOME OF THE CRITICAL WAYS THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THE JUSTICE
INVOLVED WE HAVE A BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY. THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
IN- SPEED D. N. B. C. C. R.
WHERE OF THIS WORK. I WANT
SPEAKER WITH C. B. D. A. WHOSE-
TO TESTIFY AND WE ALSO HAVE AN
EXPERT- FROM- S. P. D. THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- STANDING BY
FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
OKAY IF YOU'RE TWO WITNESSES ARE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES EACH. YEAH THEY'LL BE
JUST LESLIE MY NAME YEAH. RIGHT
GOOD MORNING SHARE BRADFORD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
LESLIE CALDWELL. ONE ACCOUNTING
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION I AM SPEAKING TO YOU
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN ON BEHALF OF
THE PDA AND AS A FORMER PUBLIC
DEFENDER HAVING RUN IN MEDIUM
SIZED PUBLIC DEFENDER OF THE- F.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTEEN WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER THE LX P. D. TO AWARD.
MINISTER GRANTS TO IMPROVE
INDIGENT DEFENSE SERVICES.
CURRENTLY MOST INDIGENT DEFENSE
GRANTS ARE ADMINISTERED BY THE
BOARD OF STATE OKAY MUNITY
CORRECTION TO BE FCC. THE V. FEC
ALREADY HAVE MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDING MANY
STATE GRANT. THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER HAS THE
NEWLY CREATED INDIGENOUS
IMPROVEMENT DIVISION. THAT HAVE
EXPERTISE IN WORKING WITH
INDIGENT DEFENSE ORGANIZATION IN
OUR STATE AND UNDERSTAND HOW
GRANT MONEY WOULD BE MOST
BENEFICIAL TO THE CLIENT- BY
PUBLIC. DEFENDERS AND APPOINTED
COUNSEL. IN GIVE ME AN DEFENSE
MAY ARE VERY GOOD THROUGHOUT
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES OF CAL FROM
URBAN TO RURAL SPARSELY
POPULATED TO HEAVILY POPULATED-
FTD IS UNIQUELY SITUATED TO
AWARD GRANTS TO THESE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES. FOR THE IMPROVEMENT OF
INDIGENT DEFENSE FOR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AFTER DIRECTOR OF A
MEDIUM SIZED PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE I STRUGGLED MIGHTILY OVER
YEARS TO GET THE FUNDING I
NEEDED TO SERVE OUR CLIENTS. I
WOULD SUMMARILY DISMISSED MANY
TIMES BY THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATOR WHEN I ASKED FOR
THE MONEY I NEEDED TO ADEQUATELY
SERVE OUR CITIZENS. THE FACT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR SAW THE NEED AND THE
DRESS DID OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'RE QUITE CERTAINLY A
LIFESAVER FOR MANY. NOW IS THE
TIME TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
PRECIOUS FUNDS ARE NOT USUALLY
KNOWLEDGEABLY AND EFFICIENTLY.
DISPERSED BY N. H. WITH THE X.
TO MAKE A LITTLE GO TO
ADMINISTER. AND MOST OF THE
MONEY GOES TO THE INDIGENT
DEFENSE SERVICES THEY ARE THE
MOST IN NEED AND BEST ABLE TO
SERVE. OUR COMMUNITIES BY
AUTHORIZING THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER TO DIRECTLY ADMINISTER
GRANTS THE PROCESS BY WHICH
MONEY IS DIRECTED IN OVERSEEING
WILL BE MORE STREAMLINED AND GET
TO THE RECIPIENTS OF THE GRANTS
FASTER. FORTY THREE FUNDS ON
BEHALF OF C. B. D. A. I HEARD
YOUR IDEA OF AN F. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOW OVER MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB HELLO IN SEVENTEEN. GREAT
THANK YOU THE MORNING SETTERS
DERRICK MORGAN FROM THE L. BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS ANTHONY
DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WILL
GO TO OUR PHONE LINES MODERATOR
TO HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
WANT TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
YOU HAVE ONE IF YOU WOULD BE
JUST ONE MOMENT.
MY TWENTY FIVE YEAR LINE IS OPEN
. I CAME HERE WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- STATED IT'S NO
LISTED OPPOSITION ON THIS ISSUE
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN TWENTY
TWO ARE YOU WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN. EIGHTEEN NO ONE I
WILL NOW GO TOOUR MODERATOR
WILL GO TO PHONE LINES IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY. THANK YOU DEAR. A POST
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND I
WANT TO ASK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS
CENTRE SCANNER OR MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR SCANNER ANY OTHER
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS OR CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS ROGER. YOUR NAME
. AND SENATOR MICHAEL TALK TO
CLOSE RESPECT. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE OKAY. COUNSEL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON US VIA
ELEVEN. SEVENTEEN WE HAVE A DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. SP
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D SHOW VOGUE. JOBO
GUY COME LONGER I COME LIKE
ARISE SKINNER. SKINNER I WINNER
WINNER I. BY ZERO FIVE ZERO THE
MEASURES OUT AND KEYS SENATOR
BRUCKER- I SEE NO OTHER. AUTHORS
HERE- RIGHT ON TIME. EGGMAN WE
WERE ABOUT TO PASS YOU. YEAH ARE
WE HAVE SOONER FIXED TIME WE
HAVE A SENATOR GRAHAM WITH S. B.
TWELVE ALL NIGHT WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. YOU KNOW
THERE ARE A LOT OF COMMITTEES
TODAY. BUT HERE WE ARE IN PUBLIC
SAFETY SO THAT'S WHAT WE'LL TALK
ABOUT NOW. THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT. AS P. TWELVE OH NINE
TODAY. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING ON THE
AMENDMENTS IN ALCESTER CORRECTED
DRAFTING ERROR- AND THIS WILL BE
A FAMILIAR ISSUE- TOO MANY OF
YOU BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN SIMILAR
BILLS BEFORE MOST RECENTLY
CENTER MEN'S BILL THAT PASSES
COMMITTEE YOU MANAGED FOR THE
LAST YEAR. SPIE SEVEN SIXTY
THREE AND THIS YEAR HE AND I
PARTNERED ON S. P. TWELVE OH
NINE THE KEY POINT OF THIS BILL
IS TO ENSURE THAT VETERANS THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCED TRAUMA RELATED
TO THEIR MILTARY SERVICE. ARE
PROVIDED WITH SENTENCING
MITIGATION- ED ED RELATED TO THE
TRAUMA IF THEY HAVE ALREADY
PASSED INTO LAW SO THIS IS FOR
RESENTENCING THIS IS FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN CONNECT CONVICTED-
TO WHEN THEY GO BACK FOR RE
SENTENCING SO THAT THE BILL THAT
WE PASSED LEFT OU A MASSIVE.
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE- VETERANS FOR
WHO TO WHOM THIS WOULDN'T APPLY
- DISTRICT TWO ACTIVE THAT WE
DID IN THE LAST YEAR HAS BEEN
APPLIED UNEVENLY TO THE EXTENT
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
JUDGE JUSTIN- JUST AS GOOD WHEN
LUKE NOTED THAT THE SECTION THE
LAW FAILS TO ENSURE EQUAL
TREATMENT OF ALL VETERANS. HE
ADDED THAT THE SCIENTIFIC
LITERATURE HAS RECOGNIZED THE
LATE ONSET PTSD PARTICULARLY
AMONG VETERANS WERE SYMPTOMS CAN
TAKE TIME TO FULLY MANIFEST AND
THAT THE B. ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS CAN
SUBSTANTIALLY DELAY.
VERIFICATION OF THE MITIGATING
FACTORS ASSOCIATED WITH TRAUMA-
AS CASES HAVE CONTINUED TO COME
BEFORE THE COURT JUST AS I LEAN
MORE WHO WE WORKED ON HAS
PROVIDED A STATEMENT TO THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR HAS
CONTINUED TO IDENTIFY WAYS THAT
THE LAW. IS APPLIED UNEVENLY. B.
O. THE REG. ISSUES S. B. TWELVE
OH NINE INCORPORATES HIS ISSUES
AS WELL TO ENSURE THAT THE
STIPULATED SENTENCES. UNDER PLEA
AGREEMENTS ARE INCLUDED. WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE IMPACTS
OF TRAUMA. AND HOW LONG SYMPTOMS
CAN TAKE TO MANIFEST AND HOW
THEY CAN ALTER THINKING. AND
BEHAVIOR. AT THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THOSE WITH TRAUMA FROM
THEIR HONORABLE MILITARY SERVICE
AND SACRIFICE ARE PROVIDED WITH
THAT CONSIDERATION WE'VE ALREADY
PASSED INTO LAW. AT THIS POINT
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE WITH ME TODAY- TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. IS GLENN VALIANT
AND- GREG FIDEL ON BEHALF OF THE
INITIATIVE INITIATE JUSTICE.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO MINUTES EACH.
MR VALIANT OR MR FADELL IF
YOU'RE READY- YOU'RE HERE
PRESENT THANK YOU YES SIR. HI
GOOD MORNING TEN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GREGORY FIDEL AND THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR INITIATE JUSTICE.
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB
TWELVE OH NINE AND WE THANK
SENATORS ADMIN AND MEN FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
AS A SENATOR MENTIONED THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE PROGRESS IN
RECOGNIZING. AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPACT THAT MILITARY SERVICE CAN
HAVE ON MENTAL HEALTH AND HOW
TRAUMA AFFECTS LATER DECISIONS
AND ACTIONS. HOWEVER THERE ARE
STILL VETERANS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED WHO'VE
BEEN LEFT OUT OF THIS IMPORTANT
RELIEF. THIS LEGISLATION HAS
CREATED BARRIERS FOR SOME
SERVICE MEMBERS. WHO ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH PTSD SUBSTANCE
ABUSE OR OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AFTER INITIAL
SENTENCING. FURTHER VETERANS WHO
TOOK PLEA DEALS OR RECEIVED
INDETERMINATE SENTENCES WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO BENEFIT FROM THESE
POSITIVE CHANGES A LOT. AT THE
CENTER ALSO MENTIONED CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE GOODWIN
LIU CALLED OUT THIS
RETROACTIVITY ISSUE JUST LAST
YEAR THIS BILL PROVIDES A
SOLUTION. TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
IS NOT A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARD NOR IS IT A SECOND BITE OF
THE APPLE THIS IS ENSURING A
FAIR FIRST BITE OF THE APPLE FOR
A POPULATION THAT IS SACRIFICED
EVERYTHING FOR THIS COUNTRY.
THIS BILL DOESN'T COST TOO MUCH
IN THIS DOESN'T LEAD TO
UNSUBSTANTIATED CLAIMS GETTING
AIRED OUT IN COURT. THERE ARE
PLENTY OF MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS
THAT CAN BE REFERENCED BY THE VA
OR CDCR FOR EXAMPLE. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE ALL
VETERANS ARE RECEIVING EQUAL
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW. WE ALSO
NEED TO PLUG GAPS IN CORRECT
INCONSISTENCIES WHERE THEY
EXIST. THIS MEASURE DOES EXACTLY
THAT. THANK YOU AND I URGE I
VOTE TODAY. GREAT MR VALUE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE LINE OR IN
PERSON YES I AM OKAY. YOU MAY
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING SENATORS MY
NAME'S CLAIM VALUE I LIVE IN
COSTA MESA I'M A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER. I AM THE FATHER OF A
VETERAN I HAVE LIVED THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT MENTAL HEALTH
INJURIES HAD ON MY SON'S LIFE.
HE AVERAGED MIX SPECIAL FORCES
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY STRONG
HE HAD A CONSTABLE CONFIDENCE
BUT HE DIDN'T QUITE SEEM THE
SAME WHEN HE CAME HOME. I
BELIEVE HE WOULD OVERCOME
WHATEVER WAS BOTHERING HIM I
WASN'T CONCERNED AND I WAS WRONG
. I SHOULD BE VERY CONCERNED
STRUGGLE SLOWLY GOT MORE
FREQUENT MORE PROBLEMATIC ONE
DAY SOMETHING BAD HAPPENED AND
THEN IT WAS TOO LATE SEEING MY
STRONG CAPABLE SON SO BROKEN WAS
INCREDIBLY PAINFUL. I'VE OFTEN
THOUGHT IF ONLY HE HADN'T JOINED
THE MILITARY WE WOULD NOT BE
WHERE WE ARE TODAY I DON'T
REGRET THIS SERVICE I'M PROUD OF
IT. THINGS JUST TURNED OUT BADLY
AND HERE WE ARE. P. THREE ELEVEN
SEVENTY DOT NINE ONE WAS
DESIGNED SO THOSE VETERANS WHO
SUSTAINED MENTAL HEALTH INJURIES
AS A RESULT OF THEIR SERVICE.
RECEIVE MITIGATING CONSIDERATION
AT SENTENCING. YOU DESERVE IT IT
IS RIGHT. CORRECT A PROVISION
WAS ADDED SO THOSE IMPACTED
VETERANS WHO HAD NEVER RECEIVED
CONSIDERATION WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO RESENTENCING HEARING AND THAT
WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO. THAT
LET'S GO BACK TO PETITION HAS
NOT WORKED FOR ALL IMPACTED
VETERANS MANY HAVE BEEN DENIED
RESENTENCING FOR A NUMBER OF
UNFORESEEN REASONS. S. B. TWELVE
OH NINE ADDRESSES THOSE REASONS
IT ENSURES ALL IMPACTED VETERANS
WHO HAVE NEVER RECEIVED
CONSIDERATION WILL NOW FINALLY
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE IT AND IT IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. SO I
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS PEOPLE OFTEN
SAY I SUPPORT OUR VETERANS AND I
BELIEVE MOST PEOPLE WHO SAY IT
BELIEVE IT. S. B. TWELVE OR NINE
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
THAT SUPPORT SO I'M ASKING YOU
TO VOTE YES ON THE BILL AND MOVE
IT TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE WITH.
YOUR STRONGEST RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CUSTOMER NOW
WILL GO TO THIS ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY COME RIGHT OUT. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN US SENATORS- ANY
MATERIAL ON BEHALF CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND A
PROCESS WORKER- PROUD SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT NOW WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE PRESENT AN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. OCT TWELVE
OH NINE. IN C. NINE MODERATOR
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWELVE OR NINE. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU'RE IN A POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. YOU
HAVE LINE I'M SORRY. WE HAVE
LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES ACTUALLY- I'M TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT KATHY SHAW- TO HAPPEN
IF YOU KNOW YOUR CALIFORNIA
ACTION. WHAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'M OFF PROGRAMS SUPPORT- THIS
IS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
TO THOSE WHO WANT THE PORK. ALL
RIGHT. ON THAT WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS AS RELATES TO US
RECALL NINE CENTER COME ON. JUST
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOUR WITNESS. FOR HIS
SON SERVICE. THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME SO IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER COME UNDER.
SENATOR JOE BOOK BECAUSE WHEN I
THINK SENATOR AT LIVE FOR HER.
WITH THE CERTAINTY HERE MANY
STORIES ARE VETERANS SUFFER.
WHEN THEY HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME
PROTECTING THIS THE IDEALS THAT
WE STAND FOR. AND IT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I'M SO GRATEFUL
FOR OUR MILITARY AND OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY BECAUSE THEY REALLY DO GO
OUT OF THEIR WAY IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE DEALS THAT WE- WE
ARE SO PRIVILEGED TO HAVE YOU IN
THE UNITED STATES WE MIGHT NOT
BE PERFECT FOR HUMAN BEINGS. BUT
THE IDEALS THAT THEY REPRESENT
ARE COMMENDABLE AND WE TRULY
WANT THANK THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED
AND ARE CURRENTLY SERVING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. NO SENATOR EDWIN WHICH
ARE CLOSE BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MEMBERS AND THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESSES AND AGAIN TO THE
COMMITTEE- YEAH WE SEE EVERY DAY
ON TV RIGHT NOW SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON YOUR CRANE AND WE KNOW THAT
THEIR SOLDIERS IN THERE FIGHTING
AND WE KNOW THAT THE TRAUMA THAT
WE ARE WE'RE TRAUMATIZED
WATCHING IT MEASUREMENTS LIKE
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ACTIVELY
FIGHTING WHEN OUR VETERANS
RETURN HOME. IT IS NO WONDER
THAT THEY MAY BE IMPACTED HELLO
IT IS ONLY THE RIGHT THING TO DO
TO ALLOW OUR LAWS TO PROVIDE IN
THE FULL PROTECTION AND
CONSIDERATION TO MITIGATE- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER ADMIN IN YOUR-
TESTIMONY YOU MENTION A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT. ARE YOU
TAKING THAT YES MA'AM THIS OKAY
THANK YOU. R. CANCEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WE HAVE TO PASS ONTO A
PREPARATIONS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR COLLAR. THAT'S BEFORE
NINETY PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD R.
BRADFORD IHO BOGE TURBO GUY COME
LONGER. COMMA I SKINNER SKINNER
I WINNER. ALL RIGHT THAT HAS
FOUR VOTES WILL LOSE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ACTION NUMBER THANK YOU
FOR INTERACT WITH.
IN THE THROAT YOU KNOW THROW ON
. GLOBAL MARKETS. AS B. TWELVE
OR NINE WINNER WINNER I. FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO. BILL SB TROUBLE
NINE IS OUT WITH FIVE TO ZERO
VOTE. CONGRATULATIONS THAT
ENTERTAINMENT AND- WELCOME
SENATOR BRADFORD WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU INTRODUCED SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. OKAY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE IS OVER CERTAIN-
SORRY. TEN TWENTY ONE. OH JEEZ
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT- FOSTER
WITH SP TEN TWENTY ONE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SP TEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH AIMS TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. REDUCED DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE AND ALLOW
OFFENDERS A PATH TO
REHABILITATION AND TWENTY TWENTY
A. B. THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR
DIRECTED THAT. DIVERSION
PROGRAMS BE AVAILABLE FOR ALL
MISDEMEANOR CRIMES INCLUDING DO
YOU EYES SINCE THAT TIME MANY OF
US WAS EXPRESSED THE NEED FOR
STRICT GUIDELINES FOR INSURERS
SERIAL DO YOU WHY OFFENDERS ARE
AVOIDING PENALTIES OR
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR CRIMES.
ADDITIONALLY A RECENT STATE
APPELLATE COURT DECISION RULED
AGAINST. DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR
MISDEMEANOR. DO YOU I.
CONVICTIONS OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS DO YOU I FREAKED
FATALITIES HAVE RISEN SHARPLY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ALL OF
WHICH WERE COMPLETELY
PREVENTABLE. IN FACT CALIFORNIA
RANKS ABOVE THE NATION'S AVERAGE
OUR NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR D. U.
I. FAALITIES WITH FATALITIES
INCREASING 8% OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS. THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THIS LEGISLATURE TO
PRESCRIBE SMART STANDARDS FOR D.
U. I. DIVERSION PROGRAMS THAT
WILL HELP REHABILITATE OFFENDERS
REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY. TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER S. B. TEN TWENTY ONE
ITSELF IS A VIRGIN PROGRAM FOR
FIRST TIME MR MEANER D. U. I.
OFFENDERS. SPENCER ARE REQUIRED
TO ENROLL IN A D. U. I.
EDUCATION PROGRAM. ATTEND THE
VICTIM'S IMPACT PANEL. AND
INSTALL IN THE NEXT EDITION
INTERLOCK DEVICE WHILE
PARTICIPATING. IN THE DIVERSION
PROGRAM. THESE NEW SAFEGUARDS
WILL GIVE INDIVIDUALS THE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE AND
LEARN FROM THEIR LOOK ACTIONS
AND TO PREVENT SENSELESS
TRAGEDIES CALLS BY DO YOU EYES
IN CALIFORNIA. IF THEY ARE
SUCCESSFULLY IF THEY
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM THE DEAL I
WILL NOT BE ON THEIR DRIVING
RECORD SO THEY WILL NOT FACE THE
INCREASED INSURANCE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE D. Y. BUT
THE DIVERTED TO YOU I WILL ACT
AS A PRIOR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FUTURE CONVICTIONS. THIS IS A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO PUBLIC
SAFETY AND A SIMILAR VERSION OF
THIS BILL PASSED FIVE ZERO LAST
YEAR OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
MERRY KLOTZBACH. WHAT MOTHERS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING AND RILEY
HALL WHICH STUDENTS AGAIN
STRUCTURE DRUNK DRIVING AFTER
PROPER TIME I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. AND I'LL- THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD- IS VERY.
THIS REPORT GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERRY CLASS **** I'M A FORMER
NATIONAL BOARD MEMBER OF MOTHERS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING IN AN
ACTIVE KOMET FOUNDER OF MADD BAY
AREA. I AM ALSO A NURSE AT THE
ONLY TRAUMA CENTER IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY FOR THIRTY THREE
PLUS YEARS. IN TWO THOUSAND TO
AN APPELLATE COURT RULING
IMPLORED LAWMAKERS TO CLARIFY
THE DO YOU I. DIVERSION STATUE
SP TEN TWENTY ONE DOES THAT AND
IT ENSURES THAT THERE ARE
GUARDRAILS ON THE DO YOU WHY.
DIVERSION LAW. MY SON MIDSHIPMAN
MATTHEW GLOTZBACH WAS KILLED
BECAUSE A DRUNK DRIVER. ON A
SUSPENDED LICENSE SUSPENDED FIVE
TIMES MADE THE CHOICE TO DRIVE
DRUNK AGAIN. I WAS TRAPPED IN
THE CAR AND INJURED MYSELF. AND
I TRIED TO START IT MIGHT START
CPR. BUT I COULD NOT. AS A NURSE
WHO HAS WORKED AT A TRAUMA
CENTER FOR THIRTY THREE PLUS
YEARS I HAVE NEVER FELT SO
HELPLESS. TO HEAR ANY EMPTY SAY
THIS ONE HAS NO PULSE. S. B. TEN
TWENTY ONE IS A COMPASSIONATE
SMART JUSTICE PROPOSAL AND
MATT'S VIEWPOINT THIS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT
COULD HELP SAVE LIVES FROM DRUNK
DRIVING IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
POINT OH EIGHT B. AC BECAME LAW
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES. IT
SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT S. B.
TWENTY ONE IS NOT ABOUT
PUNISHMENT. IT'S ABOUT
PREVENTION IT'S A VACCINE ON THE
CAR. IT IS ALSO ABOUT ENSURING
EVERY CALIFORNIA DO YOU ARE A
VENDOR IS GIVEN THE EQUAL CHANCE
AT A DIVERSION. A BETTER CHANCE
TO NOT BECOMING EVERY OFFENDER.
WE KNOW WE CAN'T JUST SUSPEND
DRIVER'S PRIVILEGES AND HOPE FOR
THE BEST THIS FAILED APPROACH
WAS PROVEN IN MY FAMILY'S LIFE
INTERLOCKS ARE 74% MORE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING REPEAT DUI
OFFENSES COMPARED TO A LICENSE
SUSPENSION ALONE ACCORDING TO A
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
DMV STUDY. BY ENDING BY ENACTING
SB TEN TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS TOWARDS STOPPING DRUNK
DRIVING. MADD CALLS ON THIS
COMMITTEE TO ADVANCE THIS LIFE
SAVING SMART JUSTICE PRO
REHABILITATION AND PRO VICTIM
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS CLASS BACK WE ALSO HAVE-
RARELY HALL. RARELY ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. OKAY WELL AND WHILE WE
WAIT TO SEE REALLY IS ON THE
LINE LET'S PROCEED WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE ROOM. TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SEEING NONE LET'S BEGIN
WITH OUR WITNESSES- WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FRONT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN TWENTY ONE. WE WILL BEGIN
. THANK YOU YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
AND AT THIS TIME NO ONE HAS
QUEUED UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THAT OUR MODERATOR WILL GO
BACK TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS
RILEY HALL. I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
ON THE LINE. BY LATE PLEASE
PRESS STAR ZERO IF YOU'RE ONLINE.
AND IF YOU DO NEED TO. CALL IN
PLEASE RIGHT- I'M SORRY DIO. SIX
ONE NINE EIGHT EIGHT NINE NINE
EIGHT FOUR ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS RILEY HALL
GOOD MORNING KEVIN BRADFORD AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RED HOT I'M
A SOPHOMORE AT HELIX CHARTER
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE MESA
CALIFORNIA AND I SERVED AS A
MEMBER OF THE STUDENT. CAN YOU
CHECK THE DIVISION'S NATIONAL
STUDENT LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. I AM
HERE TODAY TODAY TO CONVEY OUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY ONE. AND URGE THE SWIFT
PASSAGE OF THIS LIFE SAVING
MEASURE. IT IS AN HONOR TO
REPRESENT THE 280-005-0060 NINE
MIDDLE SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE MEMBERS OF FAT FROM
ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE. WE'RE
COUNTING ON YOU OUR ELECTED
LEADERS TO ENSURE THIS MEASURE
ADVANCES ARE DEFENSIBLE
UNNECESSARY COUNTERMEASURE TO
STOP IMPAIRED DRIVING. THIS
CHAIRMAN. HAD HEARD AND WE'RE
HERE INTO THE WHO HAVE LOST A
LOVED ONE TO THE PREVENTABLE
CRIME AND IMPAIRED DRIVING.
PROSECUTORS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
LEGAL EXPERTS WILL TELL YOU HOW
CALIFORNIANS BENEFIT FROM THE
SOUTH I ECHO THE SENTIMENTS-
MAKES CRITICAL ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE EXISTING LAW. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT EARLY INTERVENTION IS KEY
TO PREVENTING AND CHANGING
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR. THE
MOTION- LOCKS WORK. WHEN IT WHEN
THE PERSON MAKES A SELFISH
CHOICE TO DRIVE IMPACT IT GIVES
UP ON THE PLATES OF MEAT. IT'S
STILL RECOGNIZED THE INEQUITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND WORKS TO SAVE
LIVES YOUR LINES OF INCLUSION
SETTING ASIDE WILL ALWAYS
SUPPORT. WHILE I UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF PERSONAL CHOICE WHEN A
PERSON CHOOSES TO PUT SOMEONE IN
HARM'S WAY BY WILLINGLY DRIVING
OKAY WHEN THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER OPTIONS. THERE'S NO NEED.
TO RISE TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
GOOD. THIS COMMUNITY HAS A TO
STOP IT NEEDLESS OF LIFE AND
CHANGE THE CULTURE ACROSS STATE
. GET MY PEERS AND I. ON BEHALF
OF SKIN SITES GETTING ACROSS.
AND YOUNG PEOPLE IN YOUR LIFE
YOUR CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN
NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS. I ASK YOU
TO VOTE YES ON SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS HALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING AT THIS
MORNING HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
OUR WITNESSES THE SUPPORT WILL
NOT. MOVE TO I WILL FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION ON RECORD SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SCENE NINE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR VERSUS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PRINT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN TWENTY ONE
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU AND YOU
ARE OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YOU
HAVE A COUPLE ON- DIALING AND
NOW.
THANK YOU TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
YES- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS TIM CHANG
WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND UNFORTUNATELY WE
ARE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL ACTUALLY WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL. BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY DO SUPPORT THE- I ID
REQUIREMENTS THE PORTION OF THE
BILL THAT WE OBJECT TO IS THE
DELETION OF THE DRIVER DEMERIT
POINTS THAT THE DMB USES TO
MONITOR AND- READ- NEGLIGENT
OPERATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- EIGHTY WHY CARRIES
A- TWO POINT PENALTY. AND THAT
IS A SIGNIFICANT- VIOLATION-
THERE ONLY A FEW TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS THAT DO CARRY SUCH A
VIOLATION STREET RACING IS ONE
OF THEM I THINK- RECKLESS
DRIVING IS ANOTHER AND HIT AND
RUN I THINK ARE THE ARE THE
POOR- THAT CARRY A TWO POINT
VIOLATION.AND THE DELETION OF-
OR THE ELIMINATION OF TWO POINTS
ON THE DRIVING RECORD-I THINK
WE REALLY WOULD INTERFERE WITH
THE INVISIBILITY TO- ENGAGE
THESE DRIVERS IN THEIR THEIR
REHABILITATION SYSTEMS. BECAUSE
WE KNOW FROM- NUMEROUS STUDIES.
DONE ON THE M. B. NOT TREATMENT
PROGRAM THAT IT IS A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS SO FOR THESE
REASONS- WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS POSITION AND AN ORIGINAL
FOLK THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND NOTING THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WILL HAVE
A LARGER TO EXPRESS YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT END MOVING
FORWARD- WITNESSES- THAT ARE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
WILL BE- JUST NAME AND SENIOR
OPPOSITION. AND WHERE YOU'RE
FROM PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M I'M FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ALISON EIGHTY WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
TEN TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU AND
THERE'S NO FURTHER. THANK YOU
MODERATOR ON. I'M SORRY ONE MORE
TIME. WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
YOU KNOW ARE THEY GOING Q. OKAY
WOULD YOU MIND CHECKING THE
LINES JUST ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE SP TEN TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU AGAIN PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
BUTTON ZERO IF YOU'RE A PUBLIC.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES THAT TESTIFIED THIS
MORNING WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THAT. LIKE
TO MAKE. THE BILL WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL BY
SENATOR- WINNER AS SENATOR AFTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY-
HERE THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERN
BUT I THINK AGAIN REMOVING THAT
POINT IS AN INCENTIVE FOR
SOMEONE TO NOT ONLY A COMPLETE
PROGRAM BUT ALSO CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR- IF THEY FAIL TO
COMPETE COMPLETE THE PROGRAM
THEY WILL STILL BE ASSESS THOSE
TWO POINTS ON THEIR- DRIVER'S
LICENSE SO AGAIN IT'S AN
INCENTIVE FOR AN INDIVIDUAL TO-
CHANGE YOUR BEHAVIOR PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM AND HOPEFULLY
REDUCE- DO YOU I. INFRACTIONS
UP. I RESPECT LESS RELIABLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
BRADFORD- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS- DO
YOU PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
I HAVE A CANCEL TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON SP TEN TWENTY ONE.
AS B. TEN TWENTY ONE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOTH BOATING
JOB OF NOT VOTING COM LONGER HI
COMMA GRICE SKINNER. WINNER
WINNER I. WE'LL BE THAT WILL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE HAVE OUT THERE WE'RE GONNA
LAOS CENTER MAN AT THIS TIME TO
PRESENT HIS MEASURE S. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR SERMON WHEN YOU'RE
RIGHT. THANK YOU JERRY BRADFORD
MORNING MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE- SP
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
STRENGTHEN GUN DEALER STANDARDS
AND PROVIDE THE TOOLS NECESSARY
TO HELP HELP PREVENT GUN
TRAFFICKING. AS WELL AS TO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL SECURITY
STANDARDS TO PREVENT THAT FROM
GUN RETAILERS. UNFORTUNATELY
ILLEGAL GUNS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THE STATE OFTEN BEGAN AS LEGAL
FIREARM PURCHASES THAT ARE THEN
FUNNELED INTO THE LEGAL MARKET
IN ILLEGAL MARKETS. ACCORDING TO
DATA FROM THE GIFFORDS LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
MORE THAN THIRTY THOUSAND STRAW
PURCHASES ARE TEMPTED EACH YEAR.
WHILE GUN DEALERS ARE CONSIDERED
FIRST IN LINE TO MAINTAIN SECURE
AND LAWFUL TRANSFER OF FIREARMS
THERE IS NO CURRENT TRAINING
REQUIREMENT FOR GUN DEALERS AND
EMPLOYEES ON HOW TO RECOGNIZE
SIGNS OF ILLEGAL ACTIVITY. THEFT
FROM GUN RETAILERS IS ALSO A
PERSISTENT PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
AND ANOTHER WAY FOR FIREARMS TO
REACH THE ILLICIT MARKET. TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES SP THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE
FIREARMS DEALERS AND EMPLOYEES
THE COMPLETE REGULAR TRAINING TO
PREVENT ILLEGAL SALES. AS WELL
AS REQUIRE FIREARM DEALERS TO
HAVE VIDEO SURVEILLANCE ALARMS
PHYSICAL SECURITY MEASURES AND
ALSO TO CARRY A GENERAL
LIABILITY INSURANCE POLICY ALL
COMMON SENSE MEASURES GIVEN. THE
ROLE THAT GUNS IN ILLEGALLY
PROCURED GUNS CAN PLAY IN CRIME.
IN ADDITION I WILL ALSO BE
ADOPTING THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT WERE RESULT
OF NEGOTIATIONS AMONG
STAKEHOLDERS. THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL CLARIFY THAT AUDI CAN ONLY
BE RECORDED INSIDE THE LICENSEES
PROMISES AND NOT OUTSIDE. AND A
GOOD FAITH EFFORTS WE MADE TO
NOT VIDEO ACTIVITY BEYOND THE
DIRECT LINES OF BUSINESS
PROPERTY. IT WILL ALSO- THESE
MINERALS ALSO ADD ADDITIONAL
PARAMETERS ON USE OF AND ACCESS
TO RECORDING TO MAKE SURE.
THERE'S A HIGH BAR. HI
REQUIREMENT IN ORDER TO GET
ACCESS TO THESE I ALSO WILL
INCLUDE SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
OPERATION IN THE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS. NINE CONVERSATION
WITH THE CHAIR'S OFFICE. A
DRAFTING ERROR RELATED TO
BEHAVIORAL PROFILE PROFILING AND
DRUG TRAFFICKING WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION. INSTEAD OF DRUG
TRAFFICKING LANGUAGE SHOULD HAVE
SAID GUN TRAFFICKING. I'VE
COMMITTED TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE WILL FIX THESE ISSUES
AT THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY MEN AND
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE ERROR. I
KNOW OVERALL THIS MEASURE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
STRENGTHEN SAFETY MEASURES FOR
GUN RETAILERS AND PROVIDE
TRAINING FOR GUN DEALERS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE TOOLS
TO HELP PREVENT GUN TRAFFICKING
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE GONE UP SHAH
VIOLENCE INTERRUPTER FOR YOUTH
ALIVE AND BRADY. AS WELL AS
ANNETTE MILLER SURVIVOR AND WEST
OAKLAND GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ADVOCATE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. THE FIRST WITNESS PREPARED
ME STRUCTURE. HELLO THANK YOU.
THIS COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
ATLANTA- HERE IS INDICATIVE OF
THE EIGHTY ONE OF THE OLDEST GUN
VICTIMS PREVENTION. ACTUALLY
BEEN HISTORY. AT COORDINATOR FOR
COMBAT HE- CRYING BECAUSE I NEED
TO FOCUS ON HOW GREAT DOES IT
MAKE THEIR WAY INTO THE
COMMUNITY IT WAS BECAUSE OF THAT
I SEE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT I
LIVE HERE CREDIT BALANCE
INTERRUPTED THE FAMILIES EVERY
DAY. LIVES HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED
BY GUN VIOLENCE THERE ARE TOO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE EXPOSED TO GUN
OWNERS AND THAT VIOLENCE IT WAS
DIRECTLY RESULT EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TO GET GUNS. ELDER
ELDERS STILL AS IF THEY'RE HELD
HOSTAGE IN THEIR HOMES BECAUSE
THERE. ARE SO MANY GUNS IN THE
COMMUNITY. THERE DATE NOT FEEL
SAFE ALL RIGHT YEAH ARE YOU FEEL
A- IF THEY WILL MAKE A INTO THE
BECAUSE OF THE GAP. GUN BY THEY
ARE LIKE A IN STORY. PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY CAN ANSWER GUNS
BUT NOT THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO A QUALITY LIFE. DOWNLOAD THIS
TO NOR AND NO ONE HERE I FEEL
LIKE THAT. THIS IS NO WAY TO
LOOK A- BY ALARM DEALERS PLAY
EIGHTEEN. IN PRE GUNS FROM BEING
A TRAFFIC. JAM. THEY CAN PREVENT
DANGER IS GUN SALES BUT RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE NO FEDERAL LAWS
AND REGULATIONS THAT REQUIRE
DEALERS TO PUT IN PLACE BASIC
TRAINING SECURITY OR SAFETY
MEASURES AS A RESULT
INTERRUPTERS. AND OTHER
FRONTLINE WORKERS LIKE ME- THE
FOREST OR ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES
TO COMPRESS BANDAGES AFFECTED BY
GUN VIOLENCE IN OAKLAND. IT DID
NOT HAVE. IT DID NOT TO BE WAY
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS AND S. B.
ONE THREE EIGHTY FOUR IS ONE OF
THEM. THE SAY THE LEGISLATION
WOULD STRIP IN GUN DEALERS
STANDARDS OVERSIGHT AND SECURITY
IT WOULD HELP PREVENT GUN
TRAFFICKING. IT WOULD HELP
DEALERS UNDERSTAND THEM THEY
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO PLEASE
BOTH PAT COMPARES S. B. ONE
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YEAH. THANK
YOU. NOW WAS THERE ANOTHER NOT
TO LOVE AND THAT MILLER ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES EVEN THOUGH YOUR FIRST
WOULDN'T SUCCEED THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE KAMINSKI. HELLO.
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
TODAY I'M HERE AS A MOTHER AND A
SURVIVOR OF GUN VIOLENCE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN I LOST MY
YOUNGEST SON AND HIS BEST FRIEND
TO GUN VIOLENCE JUST BLOCKS AWAY
FROM MY HOME IN WEST OAKLAND.
THEY WERE NINETEEN YEARS- A FEW
YEARS LATER IN TWENTY TWENTY ON
MY BIRTHDAY ANOTHER ONE OF MY
SONS WAS SHOT. HE SURVIVED BUT I
WORRY OFTEN ABOUT HIS DAYS EVEN
AS HE LAY IN THE HOSPITAL RIGHT
NOW. I KNOW WHAT GUN VIOLENCE
DOES TO FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
I LIVED THIS DISASTER EFFORT.
THAT IS DISASTER ANY EFFORT
EVERY DAY. THERE ARE MANY THINGS
WE CAN DO TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE ONE OF THEM IS TO PASS
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THERE ARE
DEALERS WHO PROFIT FROM THE GUN
IN OUR COMMUNITY LIKE MINE THERE
ARE STEPS THAT THEY CAN TAKE TO
PREVENT THEM FROM BEING
TRAFFICKED. THEY CAN PREVENT
DANGEROUS FIREARMS SALES BUT
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE NO FEDERAL
LAWS OR REGULATIONS THAT REQUIRE
DEALERS TO OFFER BASIC TRAINING
SECURITY. ARE OFTEN SAFETY
MEASURES AND WHILE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS TAKEN SOME ACTIVE. BUT IT IS
NOT ENOUGH AS A RESULT FAMILIES
LIKE MINE BLACK AND BROWN
FAMILIES. ACROSS OAKLAND ARE
LEFT TO PICK UP THE PIECES WHERE
THEIR LOVED ONES ARE VIOLENTLY
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM. WE CAN
KEEP OTHERS FROM EXPERIENCE AND
WHAT I HAVE EXPERIENCED. S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THERE'S THE
LIFE SAVING LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD THREATEN TO GRANDE LIST
ANDERS OVERSIGHT IN SECURITY IT
WOULD HELP PREVENT GUN
TRAFFICKING. AND IT WOULD HELP
DEALERS I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO. BOTH
THE PAST S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR OUR COMMUNITY CAN'T KEEP
LOSING MARKET CHILDREN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU. NO I
MOVED BACK TO ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. IN KEYNOTE
MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE TO YOURS. CALLERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR NOW IT'S
TIME. THANK YOU AND YOUR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE THE LINE FIFTY
TWO AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
REMEMBER HERE ANYMORE- WITH
DIFFERENT IMPORT. THE QUICKNESS. THANK YOU I AM ONE MOMENT.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS MARINA DIRE I AM FROM
THE MEETUP CALIFORNIA ON A WALL
IN HERE WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION
CALLING FOR OFF BEAT IT BEING
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN THE NEXT WITNESS IS
LYING TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY HERE WE GO.
YOU CAN USE YOUR HELP. I'M
CALLING. MY NAME IS JIM MY NAME
IS FRANK LOOKS YOUNG AND I LIVE
IN CLERMONT AND- THE SURVIVOR MY
SON MY SISTER SHOT IN THE HEAD
THE LONGER SO I'M CALLING YES
NOT AN ACTION AND REALLY TURNS
THE GUN SAFETY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THREE EIGHT
FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU AND
THERE FURTHER WE- ONLINE. ALL
RIGHT NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION ARE WE HAVE ONE LEAD
UP AHA. A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NICK CRIVELLA IS DEEP
AND PERSONAL REASON FOR MARK.
SHOW ME IS ON THE PHONE MY
MODERATOR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN I
AM ON THE PHONE ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN TO HEAL UP
EMMA BRADFORD AND- THANK YOU
GERMAN BRADFORD ENGLISH WITH
THIS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. MY NAME'S NICK MILLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THAT'S
WRITTEN THIS BILL WOULD BE
IMMERSED IN ON THAT I'M A- ON
THE LIGHTS ARE ON THE THIRST TO
SET UP EQUIPMENT MONITORING
RECORD THE TRANSACTIONS. OF
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION IN
ADDITION SURPLUS OF SHIPS WILL
BE TRAINED NUMBER ONE TO PROFILE
POTENTIAL GUN TRAFFICKER OR
STRAW PURCHASE. NUMBER TWO HOW
TO ASSURE ENTERTAIN WHETHER
PROSPECT OF. FARM PURCHASE
SERVICE LAWFULLY PURCHASING A
FIREARM BY ASKING QUESTIONS OF
THAT PERSON AND THREE HUNDRED
REPORT A SUSPECTED FRAUDULENT
PURCHASE TO THE D. O. J. OR TO
THE A. T. L. FOR OF ALL
BACKGROUND CHECKS. ALL REQUIRED
THAT SEEK OUT LEGAL POTENTIAL
PURCHASERS OF FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION. EXISTING SOMEONE'S
DO NOT PASS BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND THEY'RE NOT BUYING GUNS GUNS
FROM ESSENTIALS. AND LASTLY HOW
DO YOU LEGALLY PROFILE A
POSSIBLE FRAUDULENT PURCHASER
WITHOUT VIOLATING OUR-
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS BACKGROUND
CHECK IS ALREADY VERY SENSITIVE
AND THOROUGH IN MY OWN
EXPERIENCEI'VE EXPERIENCED JUST
THE MERE ADDRESS CHANGE AND I
WAS DENIED THE PURCHASE OF SOME
SHOTGUN SHELLS FOR THIS LAST
TWENTY SEASONS. SO WE FAIL TO
SEE HOW THESE RIGHT REQUIREMENTS
AND SERVICE REQUEST DELETED ONE
OF PROPER USE OF FIREARMS. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT GUN
OWNERS ARE EDUCATED ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF FIREARM USAGE. IT
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE DOJ TO OFFERS
TRAINING COURSES AT THE ELEMENT
ON DUCT. THEM YOU KNOW YOU CAN
ARM FRACTURES. THIS COURSE WOULD
HAVE NUMEROUS QUESTIONS AND
REQUIRE A TESTING OR- BUT- THIS
WOULD BE DONE. THAT'S THE CELLS
ALREADY NOTIFICATION DANGERS OF
FIREARM USAGE SUPPORT LAWFUL AND
SAFE FIREARM USE ADDITIONALLY
THE POTENTIAL PURCHASER IS
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO HAVE
PASSED AND RECEIVED A GUN SAFETY
CERTIFICATE ON OUR SAFETY
EDUCATION CERTIFICATE OR
EQUIVALENT SUCH AS A PCA THIRTY
TWO WHICH IS A FIREARMS AND
ARREST FOR VACATION OR SIMPLY BE
CERTIFIED PEACE SIR. IN FACT A
PURCHASER LET'S GET ALL THE
QUESTIONS CORRECT NOT JUST 70%
AS WOULD REACH THE REQUIRED OF
THE SSL SELECTIONS EVER FELDER
FULLY AWARE OF THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS OF SALES AND
TRANSFERS OF ARMS AND
AMMUNITION. THAT IS WHY THEY
AREN'T AT THE FILM THAT'S A
FEDERAL FIREARMS LICENSE THIS IS
THE REAL STUFF ANY VIOLATION OR
MIS STEP IN THE PROCESS AND IT
FELT GOOD IN DANGER OF LOSING
THEIR LICENSE AND THEIR
LIVELIHOOD AGAIN THE REGULATIONS
ALREADY PLACE. HE WAS TO SAY THE
REQUIREMENTS TO OBTAIN AN SSL
FROM THE ATF ONE OF THE MOST
STRINGENT LICENSES WANT TO
POSSIBLY ACQUIRE THE BILL IS-REFUNDED IN THIS REGARD AND AS
SUCH IS NOT THE- LAW AND
REQUIREMENTS ARE CURRENTLY USE
AND EVEN BEYOND THE REQUIRED
SSL. GET A FIREARMS DEALER
LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
NUMEROUS OTHER SECURITY.
INSECURITY CARNAGE IN PLACE. NOW
AND WOULD BE RETURNED IT IN THAT
SPEECH. FOUR FINALLY- PRIMARY
CONCERN IS THAT THE IS A HAPPY
OPPOSITE OF THAT INTO THAT IT.
AND WE'LL MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES
MORE UNSAFE BY BURNING ARE
ALREADY UNDER STAFFED AND OVER
COMMITTED DOJ AND THE SENTENCE
WAS UNNECESSARY AND CUMBERSOME
REQUIREMENTS. WITH OVER TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND I'M GONNA ASK YOU
TO CONCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
PLEASE GIVE. DON'T. YES SIR IN
OTHER WORDS LET'S FOCUS ON THE
CRIMINAL AND NOT THE LOT
LIGHTING SYSTEM IN THE
INFRINGEMENT OF OUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THIS- ABILITY TO
SPEAK. UP FOR **** THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NOW WE'LL
MOVE BACK TO THE ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
MEAN AN- OPPOSITION. OF SP
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR HEARING
TINA AND NOW WE'LL GO TO OUR
MODERATOR MODERATOR PLEASE. GO
TO LINES IN THURS WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NOW'S THE TIME TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
ARE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE BLIND FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD MY NAME
IS MICHAEL AND I'M WITH THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND
LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI GOOD MORNING OUT OF THANK
YOU FOR THE UPS REMAINING TO
GAMBLE ON A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOLS OKAY
SHINNING GOVERNORS OF CALIFORNIA
AND I- IF YOU'RE CALLING IN TO
VOICE MY STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE SP THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CARLENE ELLIS AND I'M A
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION. AND DON'T
FORGET AND I'M I AM I AM A
COMPETITIVE SHOOTER AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR SURE JUSTIN
MCMAHON I'M NOT SURE OF THE
SOUTH SACRAMENTAL CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LIFE IF
YOU THINK THE HEAD. OF THE
FAMILY BOND THAT I'M A MOTHER OF
TWO MEMBER OF C. R. PA INDENTURE
COUNTY GUN OWNERS AND I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU N. LINE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JAMES O'BRIEN. LIFETIME
MEMBER OF THE NRA THE R. C. R.
P. A MEMBER STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
M. ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE OTHER
Q. ENOUGH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MY NAME IS HE'LL TELL HIM
I'M A MEMBER OF THE NRA WANTS
YOU TO PAY. K. FOR MY OWN STYLE
OPPOSITION AFTER TWO O'CLOCK.
THE YOU. THANK YOU THERE'S NO
FURTHER CRITICISM THANK YOU.
AFTER HEARING FROM BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WILL NOT BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS SENATOR WENT ON I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I DON'T
ANY QUESTIONS FOR SOMEONE TO
MOVE THE BILL AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
YOU KNOW I HAVE TO SAY- PEOPLE
WHO ARE- ADVOCATE FOR GUNS AND
WHO. HAVE HELPED ME COMPLETELY
THE STORE ON THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND INDUCE THE SUPREME
COURT TO LITERALLY. A REWRITE OF
THE US CONSTITUTION AND TO
IGNORE THE PLAIN LANGUAGE. OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT- THESE
HYPOCRITES ON THE SUPREME COURT
JUST TO BE HONEST IT SAYS IS A
LAWYER WITH A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
THE JUDICIARY BUT EXTREMELY
HYPOCRITICAL. TO CLAIM THAT
YOU'RE AN ORIGINALIST BUT THEN
YOU TAKE THE PLAIN LANGUAGE OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT WHICH WAS
ABOUT A QUOTE WELL REGULATED
MILITIA AND THEN SAY MEANS
ANYONE AN OWN ANY GUN AND IN
CITIES AND STATES CAN PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNITIES FROM GUN
VIOLENCE IT'S REALLY JUST- IT'S
SO DESTRUCTIVE TO OUR SOCIETY
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED. JUST DOWN THE STREET
FROM HERE JUST A COUPLE BLOCKS
FROM THE CAPITOL A FEW WEEKS AGO
WITHOUT MASS SHOOTING THERE WAS
A NOTETHERE AND IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY DAY NOW WE BECOME NUMB TO
IT. TO MATCH. AND WE KNOW THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
SHOOTINGS NEVER MAKE THE NEWS.
IT'S PEOPLE COULD HAVE A GUN IN
THEIR HOME OR SOMEONE SHOOT SO
IT'S JUST- AND IT'S JUST. SO
DESTRUCTIVE INVITED OUR KIDS
CAN'T EVEN. GO TO SCHOOL.
WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT WHETHER
THERE'S GOING TO BE A SHOOTING
IN THEIR SCHOOL IMAGINE THAT.
KID GOES TO SCHOOL SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT LEARNING AND
DEVELOPING. SOCIAL SKILLS AND
BEING WITH THEIR FRIENDS AND
INSTEAD THEY'RE HAVING TO LIKE
LEARN HOW TO WHAT TO DO IF
SOMEONE WALKS INTO YOUR SCHOOL.
WITH A GUN AND THAT'S THE STATE
OF AFFAIRS. THAT WERE IN AND
THIS BILL IS JUST ASKING THAT
THESE GUN DEALERS BE
RESPONSIBLE. SO THAT WE KNOW
WHO'S GOING IN AND BUYING GUNS.
SO THEY HAVE. THE RIGHT TRAINING
AND SECURITY REQUIREMENTS. M.
AND EVEN THAT'S- A THEY EVEN
OBJECT TO THAT. WAS AT THE
WILDWOOD THEY THEY'VE INJECTED.
WHEN CENTERPOINT TINO. HOW TO
BUILD SAY THAT YOU CAN ONLY BUY
ONE GUN PER MONTH. TWELVE GUNS
HERE IT'S A LOT OF GUNS TWELVE
GUNS PER YEAR YOU'RE ALL AT DOT-
THAT'S UNREASONABLE TO SAY I CAN
ONLY BUY ONE GUN PER MONTH OR
TWELVE GUNS A YEAR. AND NOW
ADDRESSING THE TRAINING AND
EVERYTHING- I'M SORRY BUT IT
THIS THIS ATTACK ON ANY EFFORT.
NO MATTER HOW MODEST TO PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNITY FROM GUN
VIOLENCE AND DEATH. IS IT REALLY
JUST DOES NOT SIT WELL WITH ME
AND I KNOW THAT THE OPPONENTS
ARE GOING TO BE LIKE WELL JUST
TAKE EVERYTHING THE SUPREME
COURT BECAUSE ALSO SAY
EVERYTHING IS COVERED. BY THIS
DISTORTED READING THE SECOND
AMENDMENT BUT WE NEED TO DO WHAT
WE NEED TO DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS IN OUR COMMON. WELL
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I
WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
THEM MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO A READING THROUGH THIS
BILL IN THE ANALYSIS YOU KNOW AS
FAR AS I CAN TELL AND CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG THIS BILL WOULD
JUST REQUIRE DEALERS TO HAVE
MORE TRAINING TO PROVIDE FOR
SURVEILLANCE. AND THEIR PLACES
OF BUSINESS AND TO ENGAGE AS A
BETTER PARTNER WITH THE DOJ.
THIS BILL IS NOT TAKING AWAY
SOMEONE'S GUNS- END. IT'S
SUGGESTING THAT YOU CAN HAVE
PERSONAL FREEDOM WHICH IS WHAT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS ABOUT
BUT IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT YOU
ARE- NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COLLECTIVE SECURITY AND SAFETY
OF YOUR FELLOW NEIGHBORS FRIENDS
AND CONSTITUENTS. AND SO WHAT WE
HAVE TO KIND OF MOVE BEYOND- THE
SELFISHNESS. OF GUN OWNERSHIP
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO PROTECT PEOPLE- GUNS KILL
PEOPLE BECAUSE PEOPLE KILL
PEOPLE AND WE HAVE GOT TO BE
HONEST ABOUT THAT. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU OKAY WELL I WANNA THANK YOU
CENTERMAN FOR THIS MEASURE I
THINK IT'S STRAIGHT FORWARD I
THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR AND I
WON'T REPEAT THAT WHICH HAS BEEN
ALREADY STATED ON THE REASONS
AND THE BENEFITS FOR THIS
MEASURE SO OUR ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AT THIS TIME- JUST TO
REITERATE THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM
THAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
DRESS IN THAT WE HAVE- BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND GUNS WERE STOLEN FROM
FEDERALLY LICENSED GUN DEALERS
HERE IN CITY CALIFORNIA OCT
THIRTY THIRTY THOUSAND STROSSEN
GIRLS WERE TEMPTED OVER THAT
SAME PERIOD- THAT IS WHEN YOU
TRY TO FIGHT ON BEHALF OF
SOMEONE ELSE GIVE THE GUY A
WEEKLY TO THAT PERSON. ACCORDING
TO DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM WE THINK
THESE ARE REASONABLE MEASURES
AND- JUST TO ECHO THE COLLEAGUES
AND MY COLLEAGUE A COMMENT TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
THIS IS THE COST OF GUN VIOLENCE
IN THE STATE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IS ASTRONOMICAL IT'S NOT JUST
THE ECONOMIC COSTS IT'S THE
EMOTIONAL AND SOCIAL COSTS
EVERYBODY THAT DIES OR IS
VICTIMIZED BY GUN VIOLENCE IS AN
IMPORTANT MEMBER OF THEIR FAMILY
OF THEIR COMMUNITY. MORE EFFORT
TO TRY TO LIMIT- SOME ASPECTS OF
THAT- BUT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR COM LONGER WE HAVE A
DEEP PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
YOU HAVE. TAKEN THE MOMENTS AND-
THAT I HAVE AND WE CAN-
COMMITMENTS AS DESCRIBED-
RELATED TO THE- DRUG TRAFFICKING
AND- GAVE YOUR OLD PROFILING
LANGUAGE AS WELL AND YOU CAN
TAKE THOSE. AMENDMENTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE IF YOU- IF I IF
PERSONALLY I'M ALLOWED TO. YES
YES THANK YOU YEAH SO THANK YOU.
CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AS
AMENDED. ATTENDED SP THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D SHOW VOGUE TROUBLED
NO COM LAGER YES SOME LIGHTER
ICE SKINNER WEINER WEINER I.
MEASURES THREE VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR APPS TO MEMBER
AND NOW WILL MOVE TO S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
SENATOR MATT. THE STRUCTURE. IT
IS DONE RIGHT- THANK YOU MR
SANDERS SAID I AM HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH WILL
CODIFY ON GOING FUNDING IS GOOD
IF THE SUCCESSFUL NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE LOCATED IN MY
DISTRICT WHILE ALSO FUNDING AND
REPLICATING A SECOND ANALOGOUS
COLLABORATIVE MODEL IN THE
CENTRAL COAST REGION LEFT TO
THEIR OWN PLANS AND RESOURCES
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA BUT TOOK
THE SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
CITIES HAVE HAD AT BEST LIMITED
SUCCESS IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS YOUTH VIOLENCE IN
THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
POST INCARCERATION. REENTRY ON
THE ONE HAND THESE ENDEMIC
PROBLEMS TEND TO DEFINE
MUNICIPAL BOUNDARIES WELL ON THE
OTHER THE OTHER INHERENTLY LOCAL
NATURE TENDS TO DEFEAT TOP DOWN
SOLUTIONS DEVISED AND
IMPLEMENTED AT THE STATE OR EVEN
COUNTY LEVELS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THROUGH A DEDICATED
BUDGET ALLOCATION I PARTNER WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
LEADERS IN MY DISTRICT TO FUND
AND DEVELOP A COLLABORATIVE
MODEL THAT COORDINATES AND ONCE
THE EFFORTS OF TEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY LISTING AND
SUPPORTING MORE THAN FORTY LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH EXPERIENCE. AND EXPERTISE
IN ADDRESSING THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF THESE COMPLEX
CHALLENGES NOW IN ITS FIFTH YEAR
OF OPERATION THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE C. D. LIBERALLY
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
DEVISING REFINING AND EXPANDING
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS AND PREVENT
YOU FILINGS TO PROMOTE
SUCCESSFUL POST INCARCERATION
REENTRY STRATEGIES AND DEVELOP
BETTER MORE EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES
PLANS FOR ADDRESSING AND SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS ON A REGIONAL
SCALE. UNDER ITS DESIGN THE
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY PUBLIC
SAFETY COLLABORATIVE MODEL
ALLOCATES 40% OF FUNDING TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENHANCE
IMPROVE THEIR HOME IS A
COMMUNITY LIAISON EFFORTS WHILE
THE REMAINING 60% OF FUNDING IS
DISTRIBUTED CROSS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ON AN R. F.
P. GRANT BASIS TO SUPPORT
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT ARE
DEEMED EFFECTIVE WERE PROMISING
IN ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF A
GIVEN POPULATION BY VIRTUE OF
THIS DELIVERY MULTI DIMENSIONAL
APPROACH THE COLLABORATIVE
BECOME A LABORATORY FOR
INNOVATIVE AND TARGETED ACTION
THROUGHOUT THE ELEVEN MEMBER
CITIES. AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
THE SUCCESS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS MEMBER CITIES
ARE. NO LONGER WORKING IN SILOS
AND INSTEAD WORK HE COORDINATION
QANTAS. PROMISING RESULTS AMONG
THOSE MEASURABLE RESULTS THE
COLLABORATIVE HELP MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE EXIT THE
STREETS. AND SECURE HOUSING IN
THE NORTH ORANGE COUNTY REGION
IT HAS FUNDED THIRTY THREE
TARGETED YOUTH PROGRAMS AND WILL
SOON SERVE AS THE FOUNDATION FOR
A REGIONAL HUB FOR COORDINATING
HOMELESS SERVICES. THROUGH ITS
WORK THE COLLABORATIVE'S ALSO
DEVELOPED A MOBILE PLATFORM AND
SMARTPHONE APPLICATIONS. FOR
COLLECTING AND SHARING
INFORMATION ON ON HOUSED
INDIVIDUALS MAKING REFERRALS
TRACKING PROGRESS AND EVEN
INSTANTLY BOOKING BEDS IN LOCAL
SHELTERS THIS PLATFORM CALLED
OUTREACH GRID. HAS PROVEN SO
VALUABLE THAT IT IS NOW TRIALS
WITH OTHER CITIES AND WITH LA
METRO. A PARTICULAR PRIDE THE
PROGRAM'S MEMBER AGENCIES EVEN
AS OUT REACH INTERVENTIONS AND
REFERRALS HAVE INCREASED. NO
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL INTERACTING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN
ARRESTED OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
UNDER THE FUNDING STRUCTURE
PROVIDED FOR UNDER SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTEEN EACH COLLABORATIVE.
NORTH AND SOUTH WILL BE REQUIRED
TO MAINTAIN AN ADVISORY BOARD TO
MANAGE APPROPRIATED FUNDS AND
REPORT TO THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS PROGRAM AT
LEAST ONCE PER CYCLE. AS
MANDATED UNDER THE ORIGINAL
PROGRAM THE SPECIAL WOULD GROW
BOTH COLLABORATES TO DISTRIBUTE
AT LEAST 60% OF THEIR FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH THE REMAINING 40% AVAILABLE
TO AUGMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOMELESS OUTREACH. AT THE MINUTE
MUNICIPAL OR REGIONAL LEVEL.
RESOLVING HOMELESSNESS YOUTH
VIOLENCE IN POST INCARCERATION
REENTRY CHALLENGES ARE OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE IN THE NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY REGION. AND IN
FACT STATE WIDE THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE HAS PROVEN ITSELF
AN INNOVATIVE MODEL FOR
IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY. AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL THAT CAN AND
SHOULD BE REPLICATED SIMILAR
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE-
I HAVE AS MY JOINT AUTHORS
SENATOR LAYERED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR-
VOTE TO DATE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM IS SOO
ELIZABETH CARRYING THE EXPECTED
DIRECTOR OF THE. NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. NEWMAN AND HIS GANG
WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY YOU. YOU'RE THE
ONLY PRIMARY WITNESS SO YA
FORMAN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS C. K. ASSISTANT TO
THE CITY MANAGER AND THE CITY
STANTON AND ON SPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
PUBLIC SAFETY COLLECTIVE. THE
CITY OF STAUNTON IS THE FISCAL
AGENT TO THIS COLLABORATIVE
PRIOR I WAS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ORANGE COUNTY
HALFWAY HOUSE YOUTH AND FAMILY
SERVICES. A NONPROFIT FOUNDED BY
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION. THIS
MORNING I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU ABOUT THE COLLABORATIVE
IN THE LAST FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS AND WHY IT MATTERS. SO
WHAT DID THE NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
REGION LOOK LIKE BEFORE THE
COLLABORATIVE FUNDING. OUR
REGION HAD A HISTORY OF
COLLABORATIVE APPROACHES TO
ADDRESSING VARIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES HOWEVER THE EXISTING
WORKING GROUPS IN THE REGIONS
WERE BOTH LIMITED IN FUNDS AND
RESOURCES CAUSING
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE COMPETITION
FOR THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. OFTEN
THOSE EFFORTS IN THE REGIONS
WERE UNNECESSARY DUPLICATIVE AND
HAD GAPS IN SERVICES. COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES WERE OPERATING
IN ISOLATION WITH NO
UNDERSTANDING THAT PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE SAME
REGION WE'RE OFFERING THE SAME
SERVICES TO SAME POPULATION. THE
RESULT OF A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION COORDINATION AND A
LOT OF WASTED TIME EFFORT AND
RESOURCE. SO WHAT DID THE NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY REGION LOOK LIKE
DURING THE COLLABORATIVE
FUNDING. WELL IT IS STYLISH OF
FOUNDATIONAL ACTIVITY.
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH MEASURABLE
RESULTS. FOR THE FIRST TIME A
NEW INCENTIVE TO COLLABORATE
WENT BEYOND DESPERATION BUT TO
INTO INNOVATION DATA AND
STRATEGY BROUGHT TOGETHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO SHARE ASSETS
AND PRODUCE NEW VALUE AND MODEL.
UNIFIED RESPONSIBILITY AND A
REGIONAL LEADERSHIP AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME PUBLIC SAFETY WORKERS
WERE BROUGHT TOGETHER WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
WORKERS TO COLLABORATE AND
COORDINATE STREET OUT REACH
REGIONALLY. MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS HAD NO
IDEA THAT THE OTHER EXISTED AND
PREVIOUSLY HAD NO OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS A BY
NAME CENSUS MANAGEMENT DATA WAS
FUNDED AND TO DATE OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
STABILIZED AND HOUSE FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE MORE ENGAGE
IN CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND
THIS WAS ACCOMPLISHED WITH ZERO
ARRESTS. THE COLLABORATIVE ALSO
INVESTED IN OUTREACH GRID THE
MOBILE APP BASED SINGLE
COMMUNICATION PLATFORM TO
OFFERED THE RIGHT RESOURCE TO
THE RIGHT PERSON AT THE RIGHT
TIME ELIMINATING SERVICE
REDUNDANCIES OR LOSS OF CONTACT
WITH CLIENTS ON THE STREET. WE
ALSO FOUNDED THE NATION'S FIRST
HOUSING AND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON'S PROJECT REBOUND. THE
COLLABORATIVE ALSO DEVELOPED A
TRAINING INTENDED TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY OF OUR FORTY FIVE
VENDOR PARTNERS TO BE BETTER TO
REALIZE THIS NEW VISION OF
REGIONAL LEADERSHIP AMONG PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THROUGH THESE
TRAININGS 94% NOTED AN OVERALL
EFFICACY SINCE PARTICIPATING
WHILE 46% MAKE CHANGES AND HOW
THEY COLLABORATE AS 73% HAD
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED THE TRAINING
STRATEGIES. THERE HAS BEEN NO
USE OF FORCE ONLY OUR REACH
EMPATHY IN ACTION THAT HAS
RESULTED IN DATA DRIVEN
PRACTICES ALL INDEPENDENTLY
REVIEWED BY KELSI FULTON SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH CENTER. THE
COLLABORATIVE MODEL MATTERS
BECAUSE IT IS A GROUND BREAKING
MULTI DISCIPLINARY PARTNERSHIPS
THAT CAUSES. THAT CREATES LEVEL
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL PRODUCING
BENEFITS BEYOND SOCIAL OUTCOMES
WE ARE CONFIDENT IT OFFERS REAL
PROMISE AND THE BASIS FOR LOCAL
EXPANSION AS WELL AS REPLICATION
ACROSS THE STATE. WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT A SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES AND STRUCTURES TO
CONTINUE TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGING COMMUNITY
ISSUES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE AND ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
. HEARING SEEN NONE NOW WHAT-MODERATOR WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES AND SEE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
MEASURE SP FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE
MONUMENT. MY NINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CARE
MEMBERS INTO THEIR O'DONNELL
WITH TOWNSEND PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF FORWARDS
AND BABAR UP ORANGE CONSTANTIA
STANTON FAURIA WHAT PALMA
ENDPOINT APART CALLED SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
QUICKNESS. AND THERE'S NO OTHER
WITNESSES THANK YOU. OKAY NOW
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION- THERE'S
NO FORMAL OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN.
NINETEEN NINE MODERATE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES NOW.
PROPOSITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
POST PLEASE PRESS. ONE TO ZERO.
AND THERE'S NO ONE LIKE YOU.
OKAY I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO U. S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTEEN. WE HAVE A MOTION VICE
SENATOR WIENER INTERNALLY TO
LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU MISTRESS AT
THAT THANK YOU MEMBERS RIGHT I
THANK YOU TO A MISS CAME FOR
COMING UP AND HOW TO COMMEND HER
ON HER WORK AS YOU WANT. I
COMMEND TO CHOOSE TO POLICE MY
AREA- CHIEF COREY SIGN IS WHEN A
PARKING CHIEF BOB DUNN FROM
FULLERTON WHO HAVE BEEN NOTHING
LESS THAN KIND OF THOUGHTFUL AND
PROACTIVE ENGAGING ENGAGING THE
LARGER COMMUNITY THIS IS A VERY
PROMISING MODEL I WOULD URGE ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES- YOU'RE INVITED
TO COME DWN TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
IT- WE SPEND IT SHOULD GIVE YOU
MUCH MONEY ON HOMELESSNESS- AND
OTHER ISSUES IN THE STATE OFTEN
WE DON'T COORDINATE. THESE
EFFORTS WELL TO GET THE LOCAL
LEVEL- THANKS TO SUE GANG WE'RE
DOINGTHAT IN IN MY DISTRICT
FOURTEEN- AND I WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY AS YOU'RE OUT OF.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROACH COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON SP FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN. AS
THE FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN BRADFORD
AREN'T BRADFORD I INTRO BOKE
TURBO GUY COME LONGER HI COME
LONGER ICE SKINNER WINNER.
WINNER ONLINE FOR ABOUT MEASURE
HAS FOUR VOTES WILL LOSE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR APPS TO MEMBER
CONGRADULATIONS INTERNAL.
WELCOME SENATOR A BROKER WE ARE
HAPPY TO HEAR S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. WILL ELIMINATE THE TIME
LIMITATION ON RETROSPECTIVE
CASES IN WHICH PERSONS CONVICTED
OF A QUALIFYING FELONY MAY FILE
A PETITION TO THE COURT TO HAVE
THEIR SENTENCE REDUCED A RECORD
THREE CLASSIFIED AS A
MISDEMEANOR. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN PROP FORTY SEVEN
RECLASSIFIED SIX LOW LEVEL
NONVIOLENT FELONIES AS
MISDEMEANORS AND AUTHORIZED
INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF
QUALIFYING FELONIES TO PETITION
THE COURT TO RE SENTENCE THEIR
PREVIOUS CONVICTIONS AS
MISDEMEANORS. PROP FORTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHED INTERNATIONAL A
INITIAL THREE YEAR ONE GOAL
THROUGH NOVEMBER FOR TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DURING WHICH-
JEWEL INDIVIDUALS COULD PETIION
THE COURT FOR RECORDS. CHANGES
AFTER THE DEADLINE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR RECORDS REQUESTS
VACATION IS AVAILABLE WITH A
SHOWING OF GOOD CAUSE
RECOGNIZING THE MASSIVE NUMBERS
OF INDIVIDUALS ELIGIBLE FOR
RECORDS RELIEF. THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED AND GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN WHICH
EXTENDED THE DEADLINE TO
NOVEMBER FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO OR LATER UPON SHOWING OF
GOOD CAUSE THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ELIMINATE THE DEADLINE FOR
SEVERAL REASONS. INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE INDIGENT AND ON HOUSE ARE
OFTEN PREOCCUPIED WITH ATTENDING
TO BASIC SURVIVAL NEEDS EVEN IF
THEY'RE AWARE OF THE VEIL RECENT
SINCE REAL RELIEF. THEY ARE
LIKELY UNAWARE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS TO PREPARE AND FILE
THE PETITIONS OR THAT THEIR
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY WILL END.
FURTHERED THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION OFTEN LACKS THE
TECHNOLOGY TO CONNECT THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND THE COURTS
TO BEGIN THIS PROCESS AND
FINALLY OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
THE PANDEMIC HAS LIMITED ACCESS
TO THE COURTS AND CREATED A
SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG. S. THREE
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD
PROVIDE A PERMANENT AND LESS
RESOURCE INTENSIVE MECHANISM FOR
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
TO SEEK RECORDS REDRESS
AUTHORIZED UNDER PROP FORTY
SEVEN. THIS IS NOT IN ANY WAY
EXPAND THE UNIVERSE OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO QUALIFY FOR RE
SENTENCING OR RE CLASSIFICATION
OR EXPAND THE LIST. OF
QUALIFYING OFFENSES THIS BILL IS
CO SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TESTIFYING TODAY. R.
LA COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
RICARDO GARCIA ENJOY WILLIAMS
DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE VOTE PROJECT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
SENATOR BRADFORD- DO WE HAVE-
JOEY ON THE LINE. YES THIS IS.
MY FIRST. THE MORNING. THANK YOU
ALL HEAR ME J. WHAT. HI JOEY ARE
WELCOME PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY
THANK YOU WHAT ABOUT CHARITY
SENATORS- MY NAME IS JOE
WILLIAMS I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
ORGANIZING A CALIFORNIA NATIVE
FOLK PROJECT IN A PROUD MEMBER
OF THE NEWER PEOPLE THE CURRENT
VALUE NEW COMMUNITY. AS YOU MAY
KNOW NATIVE AMERICANS WE HAVE
THAT ARE CAPITALIZED EFFECT
RETIRED CORPORATION RATE. THE
HIGHEST OF CLEAN ALLERGY. I'M
SURE THIS POINT YOU COULD AT
ELEVEN TEN EIGHT. ELIMINATE THE
CURRENT MEMBER FOR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO DEADLINE FOR FILING.
THE COURT. RECORDS A
CLASSIFICATION. OR RESENTENCING
FOR OTHERWISE QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS ADDED PROVISIONS OF
PROP FORTY SEVEN. WELL THE
REASON WHY I'M SO PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS IS BECAUSE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN MY FELONIES FOR DRUG
POSSESSION IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
MISDEMEANOR THE WATER WHICH WE
CLASSIFIED AS A CURRENT COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S PROP FORTY
SEVEN UNIT. SO YOU KNOW I WAS
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT AND I BELIEVE THAT
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN TREATED FOR
MY ADDICTION. NOT PUNISHED FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE AS WE KNOW
THE EXTENT. OF DAMAGE PEOPLE'S
RECORDS FOR THE REST OF OUR
LIVES AS WE ARE TRYING TO GET
HOUSING EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER.
AFTER COMPLETING ONLY PROBATION
AND- TWENTY TWENTY TWO ADULTS
AND A DRUG PROGRAM. I WILL JUST
KIND OF WHAT WE'RE CALIFORNIA TO
GO BACK TO COLLEGE AT. THE
COLLEGE. MY FIRST SEMESTER AT A
FOUR POINT NO. I'M GETTING A
STUDENT JOB CAMPBELL AT THE G.
O. P. S. YOUR ADVISOR I WAS
INFORMED BY THE HR DEPARTMENT AT
THE FELONY ON MY RECORD WOULD BE
TO COME OFF EVERYONE KNEW BETTER
JOB AT THE COLLEGE. YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE STRESS THAT WAS
ADDED TO MY LIFE AFTER THIS. IT
WAS IN ON IT. BUT I WOULD
BELIEVE THAT I WORKED HARD AND
HAD HOPED HE WOULD CHANGE THINGS
. THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
BUT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AFTER
COMPLETING A BACHELOR'S AND
MASTER'S AT CAL STATE
BAKERSFIELD. I WAS ABLE TO- RUN
OUR PROPERTIES HAVING
CAMPAIGNING KERN COUNTY. AFTER
BECOMING A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
WITH FAITH IN THE VALLEY. EIGHT
AND ACTING CURRENT COUNTY
PACIFICO NETWORK. AND WINNING IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH
OVERWHELMINGLY REPUBLICAN. AND
DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT THE. 201460%
PASSAGE RATE. THANK YOU HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR LIVER. AND THAT IS
WHAT THOUSANDS OF ASSOCIATE MANY
OF US WERE RELEASED MANY WERE
RELEASED FROM PRISON THAT VERY
NIGHT NOVEMBER TWENTY FOURTEEN
EVEN GETTING UP ALL. THEY GOT UP
AT THE COUNTY OF THEIR
RESIDENCE. BY FORTY SEVEN WITH
THE GAME CHANGER WE ALWAYS HEAR
THE NEGATIVE THAT IT'S FUN THAT
SPECIALLY TODAY THE BILLS THAT
ARE COMING UP. BUT IT WAS A GAME
CHANGER FOR MANY OF US AS I NO
LONGER HAVE TO CHECK A BOX. THAT
I WAS THE BALANCE. SO MY
DAUGHTER CAN LIVE WITH ME WHICH
WAS FOURTEEN. IN HIGH SCHOOL I
COULD PROVIDE A PLACE FOR ELEVEN
A LONGER TO CHECK A BOX. TO
RESTORE MY DIGNITY. FOR MYSELF
AND THOUSANDS OF OTHERS. ANOTHER
THING THAT WILL HAPPEN YOU'LL
BUY IT THE BODY ACCORDING TO
PROVIDE MORE TIME FOR PEOPLE. TO
CHANGE THEIR RECORDS. MANY OF
THE INTENDED BENEFICIARIES THE
PROPERTY SEVEN INCLUDING THOSE
WHO SUFFER FROM MENTAL ILLNESS.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER MAY BE
RELUCTANT TO SPEAK RECORD.
REALLY BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. NATIONALLY THERE ARE
MORE THAN FORTY THOUSAND
RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON PEOPLE
LIVING THE COLE COUNTY
CONVICTIONS INCLUDING NEARLY
FIVE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS I HUMBLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT. OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND GIVE
INDIVIDUALS MORE TIME TO SEEK
TRANSFER DIRECTLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SHOWING FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
MORNING WE HAVE A SECOND LEAD-
SUPPORT WITNESS RICARDO ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. I AM ON THE LINE
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED
SIMILARLY MISTER KERR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RICARDO
GARCIA AND I AM. A PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WHICH IS THE LARGEST AND OLDEST
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA. WHAT DOES COUNTY
PROUD BECAUSE FONTERRA SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. WILL ELIMINATE IF
PASSED THE SUNSET DATE HOW TO
FILE PETITIONS UNDER PROP FORTY
SEVEN WHICH IS A KEY ISSUE IN
TODAY'S CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM.
AT ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX NARROWLY
DRAFTED BILL THAT SEEKS TO
STANDARD IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
TO ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS ENSURES
ACCESS TO A PERMANENT AND MORE
EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR RECORDS
CORRECTIONS. AS YOU'RE AWARE
PROP FORTY SEVEN WAS PASSED BY
THE VOTERS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND CHANGE THE PENALTY FOR
SIMPLE DRUG POSSESSION AND
SEVERAL PETTY THEFT CRIMES FROM
FELONIES TO MISDEMEANORS. THIS
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE AND IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN MINUTES GAME CHANGER
ULTIMATELY A LIFELINE TO
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. THIS
SUPPORT HAS PROVED CRITICAL AS
CALIFORNIA IS NOW FACING I'M
PRESENT AND PRESIDENT SET OF
CHALLENGES. IN THE SEVEN YEARS
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PROP FORTY
SEVEN. FOOT HAS SUCCESSFULLY
REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S RELIANCE ON
HARMFUL AND COSTLY INCARCERATION
TODAY FEWER CALIFORNIANS CYCLE
TO THE JAILS AND PRISONS FOR LOW
LEVEL OFFENSES. THIS SAVES
FAMILIES ALLOW FOR COMMITTEES TO
REBUILD AND SAVE US HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT COULD
BE SPENT. ON SUPPORTING THE
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. FORTY
SEVEN IN. THE RIGHT TO PETITION
THE COURT FOR RESENTENCING OUR
RECORDS AND RE CLASSIFICATION.
NOW THE ORIGINAL DEADLINE FOR
FILING THE PETITIONS WAS
NOVEMBER FOURTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. BUT IT QUICKLY BECAME
CLEAR THAT THREE YEARS WITH NOT
ENOUGH AND THAT TO DO THAT. WHAT
DID SHE NEEDED TO DO WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE TIME AND THAT
IS WHY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A NEW
BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE AN
ACT EXTENDING THE DEADLINE. TO
NOVEMBER TWENTY SECOND. NOW I'M
HERE TO ASK YOU THAT WE ALLOW
THAT DEADLINE TO NOT PAST WEEK
STAND IT INDEFINITELY LET ME
TELL YOU WHY. FIRST NOT EVERY
ELIGIBLE PERSON I'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK RELIEF.
ADDITIONALLY KOPIN RELATED
DELAYS ALONE HAVE HINDERED OUR
COURTS ABILITY AS CASES THE LAST
TWO YEARS AND FINALLY IF THE
SUNSET PROVISIONS WERE TO STAND
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS COULD
STILL SEEK RELIEF BUT ONLY FOR A
MORE TIME. AND RESOURCE
INTENSIVE SHOWING OF GOOD CAUSE.
THIS WOULD HAVE A PARTICULARLY
DISPROPORTIONATE ADVERSE IMPACT
ON LOWERING CAP INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND BLACK AND BROWN
CALIFORNIA. PROP FORTY SEVEN HAS
SINCE ITS PASSAGE LESSONS RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN THE CALIFORNIA
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. REDUCE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL OVERCROWDING IN
STATE PRISONS. WE INVESTED MORE
THAN A BILLION HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS INTO LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
INCARCERATION FOR MORE THAN
FORTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS IT
IS HELP REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY IN THE CONTEXT
OF ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT CREATED
A PROCESS FOR CLASSIFYING OLD
FELONIES. THAT REMOVES BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND
EXTRICATION AND PROVIDES PEOPLE
WITH THE STABILITY THEY NEED TO
PUT THEM ON ELVES ON THE ROAD
TO SELF SUFFICIENCY. I URGE YOUR
I VOTE ON ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A- RECORDER
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SAID SEVENTY EIGHT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
MORGAN WITH THE ELEVATOR CENTER
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF AN ISSUE
JUSTICE HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
SENATORS ANTHONY MARTINO PROUD
CO SPONSOR CALIFORNIA'S FOR
SEEKING JUSTICE THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR AUTHORING THE BILL-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY HERE AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN NO
OTHER. WITNESSES IS SUPPORTED
HERE ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WILL BE GIVEN. THANK YOU
AND IFYOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. FIRST TIME
WILL MOVE TO A FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
FOURTEEN OF THE STATE'S MOST
POPULOUS COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR PRESSED FOR ITSELF THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IN LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN'T BE SURE
ON THE FIELD YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HENRY WOULD BE SOMEWHAT TIME
DECK- MOSTLY CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
. OF COMANCHE COURT UP YOUR
LIBERTY THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING YOU'LL BE JOHNSON
WITH CONDON PULLED INTO PORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN TEN B. EIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK OU M. LINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NINE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS THE LATEST STANDARDS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
TOWARDS SAFETY AND JUSTICE I'M
DONE IN SUPPORT OF THAT FIFTY
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONLINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JANE CAN ARE WE HAVE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU M. LINE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURIE YORK AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND JEFF
. OUR TIME DOWN IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRISTINA TINA KRUEGER- I'M WITH
CRIME DONE ALL THE COMMUNITY
DEALERS AND EVERYTHING ALL OF IT
BACK A LITTLE AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MINUS SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MONET
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND JAZZ
. HI DAN IT'S A PART OF F. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM UP
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD JUST CHECK
LINE ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL
OF OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES. SURE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
NO ONE SECURE ENOUGH AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR-
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL OUR
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW MOVE-
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION TO THE SP
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN LEAD OPPOSITION
SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES HERE. IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. SCENE NINE. THANK
YOU WILL NOW HOLD ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OR VERSUS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU AND HAVE YOUR
POST PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE HERE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MARTHA MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GAVE
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CALL
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU AGAIN
IF YOU ARE A POST PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND THERE'S
NO ONE QUEUING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOT A MODERATOR IN THANK
YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES
WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS DO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ABOUT PERFECT- WE
HAVE A MOTION SENATOR BACK OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
REQUEST YOUR I. WILL AFFECT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER
THE MOTION IS. DO YOU PASS BUT
FIRST WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. S.
MEDIC. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AS BILL LEVIN SEVENTY
EIGHT BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D SHOW
BOGO CHARBONEAU COM LOGGER
SKINNER SKINNER I WINNER WINNER
I THINK YOU AND WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OUR ABSENCE
NUMBERS THANK YOU. YOUR POPULAR
THIS MORNING SENATOR CRAWFORD
IT'S BEEN A SLOW NEWS DAY. WE
WILL NOW CONTINUE WITH S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE OKAY HAS
THREE THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WOULD
HAVE IT FOR HIM. THE PEACE
OFFICER FROM INITIATING A MOTOR
VEHICLE STOP FOR LOW LEVEL
INFRACTIONS UNLESS THERE IS A
SEPARATE INDEPENDENT. BASIS TO
INITIATE THE STOP LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAFFIC STOPS ARE
RACIALLY DISPROPORTIONATE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND REPORTS
HAVE FOUND THAT BLACK
CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE THAN TWICE
AS LIKELY. TO BE SEARCHED AS A
WHITE CALIFORNIA. OFTENTIMES
THIS IS LED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACROSS THE STATE AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THE MISUSE THEIR POWER
DURING TRAFFIC STOPS TO FISH FOR
INFORMATION OR SUSPECTED
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. WHICH
PERPETUATES MISTRUST IN THE
COMMUNITY AND LEADS TO
UNNECESSARY AND NEGATIVE
ENCOUNTERS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOME WILL CLAIM THAT SOME OF THE
STOPS RESULTED IN THE
APPREHENSION A WANTED FELON
THESE FELONS I SHOULD SAY OR
UNCOVERING ILLEGAL DRUGS OR
WEAPONS THAT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
FOUND OTHERWISE. BUT IT'S ALSO
RESULTED IN UNNECESSARY
TRAGEDIES. WE ALL REMEMBER IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IN TEXAS
SANDRA BLAND A TWENTY EIGHT YEAR
OLD WOMAN WHO WAS FOUND DEAD
INSIDE OF HER. JAIL CELL THREE
DAYS AFTER BEING PULLED OVER ON
THIS SUSPICION OF THE USE OF A
LEGAL- CHANGE LINE SIGNAL I
SHOULD SAY IN CHANGING OUR LINES
WE ALSO JUST RECENTLY DANTE
WRIGHT. WHO WAS SHOT AND KILLED
AFTER BEING PULLED OVER FOR
SIMPLY HAVING AIR FRESHENER
HANGING FROM HIS REAR VIEW
MIRROR. AND WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
THE TRAGEDY OF FOR PHILANDO
CASTILLE WALTER SCOTT AND SAM TO
BOY. WHO WERE ALL SHOT AND
KILLED BY POLICE AFTER SIMPLE
TRAFFIC STOP. JUST LAST MONTH
LAPD COMMISSION PRESIDENT
WILLIAM BRICKS STATED. GOALS
FOR. FREE TEXTURAL STOPS DO NOT
RESULT IN GUNS BEING TAKEN OFF
THE STREETS THOSE PROTECTIONS
STOPS DID NOT RESULT IN
CURTAILING MURDERS OCCURRED
TELLING SHOOTINGS THERE. IT IS
NO DATA THAT ANYONE CAN POINT TO
THAT ESTABLISHES THAT
PRETERNATURAL STOPS CURTAIL
VIOLENT CRIME IN OUR CITY. WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOCUSES THEIR
ENERGY ON PURSUING LOW LEVEL
TRAFFIC VIOLATION IT REDUCES
THEIR ABILITY TO FOCUS ON MORE
CRITICAL NEEDS IN THE COMMUNITY.
THIS BILL WOULD PREVENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM STOPPING
VEHICLES FIRST LOW LEVEL DRIVING
CODE INFRACTIONS SUCH AS-
EXPIRED REGISTRATION BUT NO MORE
THAN SIX MONTHS. FAILURE TO
PROPERLY FASTENED A LICENSE TO
YOUR CAR OR VEHICLE LA LIGHTING
MAU FOUGHT. FUNCTION LIMITED TO-
THIS- SIGNAL LIGHTS. ACCORDING
TO THE RACIAL AND IDENTITY
PROFILING ACT- BOARDS OF TWENTY
TWENTY TO REPORT THESE
VIOLATIONS ARE THE TOP THREE NON
MOVING EQUIPMENT VIOLATIONS. TO
RESULT IN TRAFFIC STOPS ACROSS
ALL RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS AS
REPORTED BY OFFICERS TESTIFYING
SUPPORTER DAY IS ONLY A PRIOR
THE EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WHY. OSTADE
CONFERENCES AND DOUBLE ACP. AND
AT THE PROPER TIME I ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
R. BRADFORD SELENA ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU- ONE ITEM
SHARING MEMBERS. CAN YOU PLEASE
PROCEED SORRY. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'M GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR
RECORD FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY I'M ON BEHALF OF
PRESIDENT RIGHT CALENDAR IN
CALIFORNIA HAWAII IT CONFERENCE
THAT. HE DIDN'T FIFTY SEVEN
BRANCH OF THE TWENTY THREE YOUTH
UNIT THANK Y. I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FEES
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WHICH WOULD
PREVENT LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
STOPPING VEHICLES FROM ALEPPO
I'M A FRACTION ON MEDICARE
ALREADY STATED CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT STOPPED ARE RACIALLY
DISPROPORTIONATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND THE LONG TERM
IMPACT OF DRIVING WHILE BLACK OR
WILL YOU CONTRIBUTE TO WIPE THAT
QUITE AND PUBLIC HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH. AND WHAT IS NOT THERE
ANYTHING TRUST AND SAFETY
TOWARDS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS- RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THE TOP THREE METERS LONG QUEST
YET- HAVE STOPPED AFRICAN
AMERICANS INCLUDE NON MOVING
VIOLATIONS SUCH A **** HEAD TAIL
LIGHT OBJECT CAME FROM- WILL
VIEW MIRRORS AND EXPIRED REGS
REGISTRATION- AND WE KNOW THAT
THE LOW LEVEL TRAFFIC STOP I
WOULD GET ANGRY WITH ANIMATION
AND CULTIVATE HERE- AT THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE WOULD HAVE
CALIFORNIA JOINED PHILADELPHIA
PENNSYLVANIA WHICH IS THE ONLY
CITY IN THE NATION. WITH EXACTLY
QUALITY BUILT SO DIRECTLY AFFECT
HOW DO YOU WANT THE TENSION OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR ESPECIALLY
AFRICAN AMERICANS DURING NON
PUBLIC THANK YOU STOPS WHAT
CREATED BOXES IF THEY ONLY
CHARGED THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE I
AM A QUICK MEASURE TO STOP
RACIALLY DISPROPORTIONATE
DOCUMENTS STATE. OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MUCH- SELENA. WE HAVE WE WILL
NOW CAN WITH OUR SUPER WITNESSES
HERE- FOR SPT EIGHTEEN HERE ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. HELLO AGAIN
DEREK MORGAN WITH THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WILL NOW CONTINUE WITH
AT WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY
THE OTHER TELECONFERENCE RSS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU KNOW AND IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN ACTOR'S CALLERS
LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LESLIE CALLED LOKI STANFORD PUP
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION INTERCOURSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEVER GO TO LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HI CHRISTINA CAN IMPROVE WITH
TIME DARREN AND- COMMUNITY
HILLARD AN IMPORTANT FEATURE TO
MAKE IT WORK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT WE
MIGHT BEGIN WITH AT THE JUSTICE
GROUP AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO HI HELLO MY
NAME IS OR YOUR WORK AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF- I'M SORRY IF THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR-
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL OUR
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOM
ANY OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD- OPPOSITION OUT WITNESS-
YES WE DO NOT HAVE ONE ON
RECORD. WE WILL NOW BEGIN WITH
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CORY CELLS ALONG BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTIVELY IN
OPPOSITION. FIRST WE OBJECT TO
THE POLICY OF KEEPING LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM ENFORCING THE
LAW. THE LOW LEVEL INFRACTIONS
DESCRIBED AS BILL RELATED TO
VEHICLE SAFETY RIGHT AND IF
OCCASION AND IF THEY'RE
IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO BE KEPT ON
THE BOOKS. POLICE OFFICERS
SHOULD NOT BE TOLD THEY MUST NOT
ENFORCE THEM UNLESS THERE'S A
SEPARATE VIOLATION. ADDITIONALLY
THE EXCEPTION TO ALLOW STOP FOR
AN EXPIRED REGISTRATION ONLY OF
THE REGISTRATION IS MORE THAN
SIX MONTHS EXPIRED. IS IN
PRACTICE NOT VERY HELPFUL
BECAUSE IT MAY NOT BE REALLY
APPARENT OR EASY FOR PEACE
OFFICER TO ASCERTAIN THAT LITTLE
DETAIL WITH TWO VEHICLES IN
MOTION. ALSO TRAFFIC STOPS FOR
VIOLATIONS DESCRIBED AS BILL
ROUTINELY RESULT IN ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS FOR MUCH MORE SERIOUS
OFFENSES. IN MANY CASES
UNDERTAKEN OFF THE STREET DRUGS
ARE SEIZED AND OTHER CRIMES ARE
UNCOVERED IN THE PROCESS OF A
TRAFFIC STOP. FOR THESE REASONS
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LITERALLY ON THE BEHALF OF
HER SECOND SHARES FARMAN AND
SHARES HAD BIANCO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES HERE ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED- WHEN I THINK THAT WOULD
ASSIST YOU CAME THIS MORNING TO
TESTIFY WILL NOT MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND WILL
MOVE TO THE LINE OF SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
RANDY PERRY WITH THEIR READERS
SO SITS ON BEHALF OF POOR ACT
AND THEIR SCALP RESUSCITATION OF
THE TROLL IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED HE THAT'S. ONE ZERO. AND
THERE'S NO ONE I THINK YOU THINK
YOU MATTER MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE HER CLIENTS ONE MORE TIME
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
ALL OF OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU AND AGAIN IF
YOUR POST PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR AND
THANK YOU TO OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
REMEMBER CERTAIN MEMBERS HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. WE HAVE A MOTION
TO THE BELL. AND CENTER SOME OF
HER YEAH I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT- YEAH I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL FOR VERY OBVIOUS
REASONS YOU KNOW TRAFFIC STOP
SHOULDN'T BE USED- AS COVER. TO
VIOLATE PEOPLE'S RIGHTS- AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT THE
LAW OF AVERAGES SAYS THAT IF YOU
STOP ENOUGH PEOPLE YOU WILL
EVENTUALLY FIND WHATEVER IT IS
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR BUT THAT
IS NOT THE INTENT OF LAW. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING
TO STOP. THANK YOU SENATOR CUMAR
. OKAY I THINK YOU ARE SENATOR
PRATT FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU AND I THINK
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S MY BILL
BUT WE'VE SEEN HISTORY- AND IT'S
PROVEN- THE DISH PORTION IT
NUMBER OF TIMES THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR HAVE BEEN STOPPED THAT
HAVE LED TO- I'M SORRY ABUSE
DEATH AND UNNECESSARY
INCARCERATION AND I STAND HERE
AS A VICTIM. WHO HAVE BEEN
STOPPED THREE TIMES AS A STATE
LEGISLATURE TWICE BECAUSE THEY
SAID I NEVER SAW A RED A ON A
LICENSE PLATE BEFORE- THE SECOND
TIME I WAS STOPPED BECAUSE- WE
STOP YOU BECAUSE YOUR HEADLIGHT
WASN'T WORKING ON YOUR CAR BUT
THEN I WAS FORCED OUT OF MY CAR
TO DO A SOBRIETY TEST THAT. I
PASSED WITH FLYING COLORS AND
THIS IS HOW DO I GO FROM HAVING
A HEADLIGHT TO JOIN A SOBRIETY
TEST WILL YOU LOOK SUSPICIOUS
SO. ANYWAY SO THOSE THINGS
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN AND IF THEY
HAPPEN TO ME IMAGINE WHAT IT
HAPPENS TO AGAIN SO MANY FOLKS
WHO. DON'T KNOW THEIR RIGHTS AND
DON'T KNOW LOSS AND IT LEADS TO
AGAIN- ON NECESSARY SEARCHES OF
VEHICLES MANY TIMES WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE NO INTENTIONS OF COMMITTING
CRIMES. SIMPLY BECAUSE THEIR-
BLINKER DIDN'T WORK OR- ARE YOU
STILL THERE TACKS WERE SIX
MONTHS. LESS THAN SIX MONTHS- AS
THE BILL STATES AND THAT'S NOT
HARD TO DISCERN IF IT'S APRIL OF
THIS YEAR IN YOUR- DEBT TAX
EXPIRED IN DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I THINK ANY
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL KID CANAL
THAT'S WITHIN SIX MONTHS AND-
WOULD NOT STOP THEM OR HAS IT
EXCEEDED THAT THEY'LL KNOW IT'S
MORE THAN SIX MONTHS SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
MEDICUS HELTON PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL BRADFORD R. BRADFORD I'D
SHOW BOKE NO TROUBLE NO. COM
LONGER HI COMMA GRICE SKINNER.
SKINNER I WINNER WINNER I'D
VOTED FOR ONE. AND THE BUILD UP
HOUSES. FORTY ONE. VERY POLITE
I'M ON EVERYTHING. WELL THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA WE'RE GONNA
LOOK TO CALLS FOR- THOSE-OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT MEMBERS
WERE ABSENT FILL COUNCIL EDGE
YOUR COMMUNITY CAN WOULD LOVE TO
CALL FOR THOSE CUSTOMERS S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MEN DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SCANNER. SKINNER I IT'S FOUR TO
ONE. THAT MEASURES OUT FOR THE
ONE SP FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN NEW
MEN- CURRENT PHOTOS FOUR ZERO DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATION SKINNER.
SKINNER I FIVE ZERO. THAT
MEASURES OUT FIVE ZERO TEN
TWENTY ONE BRADFORD CROWN VOTE
IS THREE ZERO SCANNER. SCANNER%
HI FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO THAT
MEASURES OUT- SP ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT BRADFORD CURRENT PHOTOS
THREE TO ONE COM LONGER FROM
LAGER I AND THAT IS FOUR TO ONE
FOR THE ONE THAT MEASURES OUT I
BELIEVE THAT IS IT LET ME DOUBLE
CONSENT. WE DID CONSENT WE DID A
MOMENT.GO RIGHT WHEN YOU CAME
IN. ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT. WELL
LET ME THINK THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN TODAY'S TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE. TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THIS
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
PARTICIPATION I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE AGAIN FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED TODAY'S AGENDA OF THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WE STAND ADJOURNED.